it had happened again some absolute
schmuck of a junior researcher had left
a certain door ajar the door that kept s
SCP 049 the plague doctor locked in his
containment chamber as a result the good
doctor had wandered out and given the
junior researcher a hug of appreciation
for freeing him leaving his dead body
sprawled out across the ground typical a
problem solving itself but this time the
problem had been a little more severe
than just the one responsible facing
immediate consequences of their actions
the BL doctor had grabbed the junior
researcher's corpse and dragged him back
into his cell leaving the door once
again slightly ajar with a variety of
equipment from his magical medical bag
the doctor had transformed the junior
researcher's corpse into a disfigured
zombie in hopes of curing him of the
pestilence and released him into the
facility 049 had followed him out to
observe his behavior and in the process
he'd given several guards and members of
janitorial staff a congratul ulatory
hand touch sending them to early Graves
by the time people realized what was
going on six people were dead several
zombies were wandering around the
building and 049 was spotted in a lab
stealing medical equipment Dr cleff Who
was on duty at the time was getting sick
of this nonsense this was actually the
third breach that the plague doctor had
been involved in this month and it was
only the 14th he was frankly ready to
wash his hands of this particular
anomaly because it wasn't just the fact
that the plague doctor killed people
that bothered Dr cleff after all Dr
cleff himself had killed a considerable
number of people it was the fact that
the plague doctor was also so damn
sanctimonious about it klef breathed a
sigh and rubbed his temples to subdue
the incoming headache it was time to
have a little tribunal and decide what
disciplinary action he would take
against this freaky physician the plague
doctor was on his knees locked into
place by heavy chains and restraints
around his neck arms arms and legs these
weren't even official Foundation
property Dr cleff had brought them in
from his private Leisure room back at
his house as usual the doctor was
preaching the immense value of his work
the pestilence runs R Dr clef surely you
must see that the doctor cried you're a
man of science yourself allegedly surely
you can empathize with my mission I just
want to help people can't you see I'm
just like you blah blah blah always this
goddamn pestilence do you ever turn off
CL said waving away the doctor's words I
don't know about your pestilence but I'm
definitely looking at a pest right now
what the hell am I supposed to do with
you no matter what allowances we give
you you just keep escaping the doctor
hung his head he hated when people
treated him like this like some wild
animal of course occasionally people
died but it was only in the pursuit of
saving so many more lives he tried to
convince Dr cleft that the costs would
pale in the face of the rewards but the
gung-ho Foundation researcher simply
wasn't interested in hearing it instead
he was brewing up a new idea one that
might rid him of the plague doctor
forever even without breaking the
foundation's goofy rule against killing
anomalies you know what Dr kle said
affecting a voice of mocked kindness you
finally got your words through my thick
head I get it now I get how important
your research is all this time we've
been stepping in the way of no
prize-winning work I don't know how I'll
ever live with myself for this I just
want to say personally on behalf of the
SCP Foundation we are truly sorry
suddenly the plague doctor perked up my
goodness he thought I've finally gotten
through he was practically vibrating
with Glee your apology is accepted good
sir the plague doctor proclaimed let us
not obsess over the past we will look
towards the future exactly Dr cleff cut
in that's why by way of an apology I
plan to reassign you to a special
research facility where you get to run
the show you'll have live test subjects
of Plenty and no accountability to the
foundation whatsoever ever how does that
sound to you doc the plague doctor
somehow Rose to his feet despite the
chains perhaps propelled by the sheer
force of his love for science I suggest
we leave at once he said thank you Dr
cleff you kind kind man I always knew
that you were the reasonable one even Dr
cleff had to resist the urge to laugh
about that one smash cut to the next day
when Dr kleff the plague doctor and a
group of mobile Task Force officers were
crowded into a helicopter heading
towards SCP 3008 Al known as the
infinite Ikea of course the plague
doctor didn't know that he thought he
was heading towards the state-of-the-art
research facility that Dr cleff promised
him cleff on the inside reason that what
this bird brain didn't know
wouldn't hurt him the helicopter landed
within the perimeter established around
the abandoned Ikea and the plague doctor
was herded off the vehicle he' bought
clef's lie Hook Line and Sinker and as
such was unusually Cooperative with the
guards Dr C pointed to the building and
instructed the plague doctor to head
inside and just keep walking he'd find
the test subjects and the facilities
soon enough and why would the foundation
be lying to him they'd even let him take
his medical bag in there when you get in
there ask for Hugh he'll be your lead
assistant Dr clef told him lead
assistant you mean to tell me I will
have multiple research assistants the
plague doctor said oh Splendid I cannot
wait to meet this Hue oh yeah Dr gleff
said biting his bottle lift to stifle a
laugh his name's Jass be sure to mention
that it'll help speed along the process
the plague doctor nodded his head in
thanks much appreciated Dr cleff rest
assured I will not forget this kindness
as the plague doctor wandered into the
abandoned store his heart swelling with
pride Dr klef began to quietly laugh
behind his back like the big old jerk
face he was when he could no longer see
the plague doctor clef turned to one of
his colleagues and jokingly asked does
that mean we'll need to reclassify 38 as
thel now not looking forward to that
paperwork on the inside of the infinite
Ikea the plank doctor was chuckling to
himself with Glee after all these years
of hard work his Merit had been
recognized and he'd been given the
respect he deserved from his peers at
the foundation he was so wrapped up in
his own sense of personal Pride that he
didn't even register it as strange that
he was surrounded by odd sterile living
rooms bedrooms bathrooms and kitchens
all in a seemingly random configuration
with signs next to them in a mix of The
King's English and what he believed to
be some form of Swedish that he didn't
quite understand still he didn't mind
too much he just assumed that these must
be the accommodations for himself his
patients his test subjects and his
research assistants and to think they
built this whole place just for him and
his research it lifted his soul to know
that the SCP Foundation had finally
recognized the pestilence for the danger
that it is from now on everything would
change he'd probably find the Cure in
the next few few years then it suddenly
occurred to him he was a little lost the
layout of the research laboratory was
incredibly strange it seemed like an
utterly arbitrary configuration of
bizarre rooms separated by wide aisles
it didn't seem sanitary at all where
were the sealed Laboratories the gurns
the patient beds the medical equipment
and on top of all that where was Hugh
some kind of shenanigans were foot that
much was clear now the plague doctor
quickened his pace through the halls of
this strange building one way or another
he would get to the bottom of this
nothing would get in the way of the
important research he planned to conduct
here after what felt like hours of
aimless walking the plague doctor
encountered some other sentient beings a
group of three people wearing ragged
post-apocalyptic looking clothes all
carrying defensive kitchen knives and
hammers the doctor was overjoyed to see
these people he could actually converse
with the others upon seeing him were a
little taken aback had some renfair
cosplayer somehow accidentally wandered
into to the building what on Earth was
going on here excuse me good s the
plague doctor called out I'm searching
for a q Jazz that caused the group to
break into laughter immediately
lessening the tension the deao leader of
the group Calvin replied aren't we all
049 didn't get it but these humans
nonetheless like the cut of this new
guy's jib all three of them had been in
here for at least a year each and it
been a while since they had a good laugh
in this terrible Labyrinthian Place
Calvin steep forward lowering his
weapons now that he could see that this
weird cosplayer guy didn't seem like a
threat he cleared his throat and asked
mind if I ask who you are fella the
plague doctor was taken aback by this
question did they not prepare you in
advance for my arrival the group shook
their heads how strange the plague
doctor said well I suppose some proper
introductions are in order then I am
your new leader as appointed by Dr cleff
of the SCP Foundation I'm a reasonable
man a man of science and under my leader
ship we will be a scientific Force the
likes of which the world has never seen
together we will cure the pestilence and
save all of mankind there was a long
pause after that none of the group of
humans really knew how to react to this
Calvin thought to himself great we got
ourselves a major space case let's get
him back to the camp before he gets
himself killed he forced a smile nodded
pretending to be impressed by the plague
doctor's bizaar ranting well then doctor
he said we better get you back to our
camp we're not going to get anything
done while we're just standing around
will we the plague doctor couldn't agree
more he followed the group of his three
new research assistants further into
this incredibly strange scientific
building the plague doctor indeed
appreciated Dr cleft putting all this
together for him but he would privately
indulge in the thought that Dr C
seemingly could not put together a
laboratory to save his life this place
was a bizarre confusing disaster but he
would still make it work one way or
another however his musings were
interrupted When the Lights Went Out the
three people within and began gasping in
shock and horror Calvin was repeating to
himself no this is impossible I timed it
I swear I timed it but the plague doctor
found their attitude to be utterly
baffling these were supposedly to be
Intrepid men of Science and yet they
were afraid of the dark it seemed they
really did need his leadership to get
anything done here follow me gentlemen
the plague doctor said it's merely a
failure of the lights I'll get this
rubbish sorted out he began to walk
forward as the three human beings began
to panic behind him telling him that if
he keeps walking he'll die he needs to
come back they need to stick together
but he kept walking he didn't get this
far by being a coward after all at least
the others are following him now
wielding their Hammers and kitchen
knives he'd whip them into shape then
his attention was stolen by something
altogether stranger it was a creature
humanoid but not human standing about 10
ft away from him seemingly ignorant to
his presence the blank doctor was
simultaneously fascinated and horrified
by what he saw before him it was in some
kind of yellow and blue uniform with a
hideous mouth formed faceless head and
two long Tangled arms that it dragged
along the floor behind it like an
orangutan it was a truly repulsive
pitiful creature one that made the
plague doctor sad to even look at it
clearly this had to be an advanced case
of the pestilence while the plague
doctor was filled with scientific
curiosity his three human traveling
companions were filled with Terror they
were still so far away from the camp and
the staff had found them already because
there's never just one they're like big
deadly cockroaches if you can see one
more are on the way their best bet is
just staying incredibly quiet and trying
to sneak past hello there you poor
fellow the plague doctor said stepping
forwards and waving it seems you're in
dire need of some medical assistance
Calvin and his two companions were
mortified so this was how they were
going to die after making the mistake of
being kind to a clearly deranged man
dressed as a medieval plague doctor
doctor what a way to go the second had
heard the plague doctor's voice the
member of staff was activated as were
several others in a 10 m radius they all
suddenly stood upright muscles taed with
violence waiting to happen they began
chanting their dreaded phrase the stor
is now closed please exit the building
while converging and running towards the
plague doctor like a pack of hungry dogs
it was a terrifying sight to behold but
not for the plague doctor himself there
were so many of these poor fected people
and clearly the pestilence had not only
warped their bodies but broken their
minds after all this wasn't a store this
was the new Research Center specifically
designed for his research Dr kleff would
surely never just lie about something
like that he was an honorable man then
again maybe that was exactly why clef
had sent him here so many victims of
advanced pestilence would make perfect
test subjects a paradise of research the
plague doctor couldn't be happier as a
group of 10 and staff members converged
on him Calvin and his men could barely
look the new guy may have been crazy but
he didn't deserve to go out like this
however the last thing they expected was
for the plague doctor to calmly raise
his hands allowing the members of staff
to run right into his deadly touch in
the following moments all 10 of them
were lying on the ground dead the three
men were utterly speechless what had
just happened had the man in the strange
costume snuck in a secret knife or a
silenced gun had he gone into some hyper
Advanced instant kill Kung Fu move that
was simply too fast and subtle for them
to perceive or had he really just killed
10 members of Staff in mere seconds just
by touching them the plague doctor
turned to them and said well then
gentlemen let us not Dilly grab one each
and will carry them to the laboratory on
the double soon after the plague doctor
and his three research assistants
arrived at a nearby encampment several
other members of staff had attacked them
on the way but a single touch from the
plague doctor had killed each one the
human's perspective on this mysterious
stranger had changed entirely he'd gone
from a goofy crank to a Godlike Savior
for as long as they'd been in here
they'd lived in Terror of Staff but they
were nothing to this man with a single
touch from him they were gone forever as
the doors of the camp were closed behind
him the people of the camp began running
towards them confused and curious the
plague doctor was delighted to see that
there were so many other research
assistants here to help him on his
Divine Mission Dr clef that beautiful
sweet man had given him such a boon
perhaps now the pestilence May finally
be cured one of the camp leaders ran
over Furious and yelled what the hell
are you doing you know you can't just
bring those bodies in here it'll only
attct more of them you fool fool the
plague doctor found this rather rude but
he'd Overlook it for the sake of the
greater good he'd spent his whole life
dealing with the aspirations from lesser
intellects who couldn't even begin to
understand his work the masses rarely
understand processes only results and
here he knew he would be able to give
them results wor not good sir I am a
medical man the plague doctor said
simply walking past the Nayer and
bidding his first three research
assistants to drag the bodies after him
I will bring this place up to code you
will see soon enough that my scientific
leadership is second to none now I will
retire to my office and begin dissecting
these samples before the camp leader
could say anything else the pl doctor
had retired into a staff room which had
been retrofitted as a kind of
headquarters for members of the camp
that's when Calvin approached the camp
leader and told him the astonishing news
look boss I know he looks like a
goofball in a Halloween costume he said
but this guy he's special he's something
else he can kill the staff the camp
leader scoffed so can we he said Calvin
shook his head no you don't get it boss
not like us this guy he can kill the
staff just by touching them and the camp
leader had no response to that in his
new study the plague doctor was
dissecting one of the Dead staff members
and was astonished to see what was
happening within the creature had no
organs it was simply that strange
slightly yellow tissue all the way down
he'd never seen the pestilence have such
a profound and horrific effect on its
victims it had horribly altered them all
the way to the core was this what the
great dying was truly capable of in its
later stages the plag doctor shuddered
both with horror and scientific excit M
he'd barely been here a day and he'd
made some of the most incredible
discoveries he took fastidious notes on
these new Revelations feeling the
picture coming together in his mind his
deep scientific thoughts were
interrupted by the door opening and
Calvin and the camp leader stepped in
the camp leader was different than
before he had none of the Bluster and
arrogance of his first words he showed
fty like he was standing in the presence
of a Divine being I I'd like to formly
welcome you to our camp doctor the camp
leader said we're extremely fortunate to
have you here please if you need
anything don't hesitate to let us know
we are truly At Your Service the plank
doctor was delighted to hear this with a
polite nod he replied more pest subjects
like these will do just fine good sir I
believe I am very close to a
breakthrough here oh here we go again
it's time for us to take another crack
at putting SCP 682 6 ft under once and
for all if you've been following this
channel for any amount of time then
there's one thing you know for certain
SCP 682 is harder to kill than pretty
much well anything we've made multiple
videos on the foundation failed attempts
to finally terminate the Beast and we've
made a video with some of your ideas on
how to finally slay the monster and
considering you're watching this video
right now you can probably guess how
that went now it's time for one more run
at the Death Star and once again it's
with your ideas from comments and
Community post responses let's see if
any of them can help us finally put this
ill-tempered reptile to rest if we can't
well we're not blaming you but it's also
your fault let the community termination
attempts commence AAS McBride suggested
ask the witch child SCP 239 also known
as the witch child is one of the most
dangerous and Powerful anomalies out
there she's a small girl with
unparalleled reality warping mental
abilities so powerful that her very
brain waves alone can be passively fatal
however the problem is her her power is
so potentially dangerous that she's
forever kept in a kind of medically
induced anomalous coma Dr Alto CLE
thinks she's so dangerous he's even
campaigning to have her terminated as a
result the 05 Council has forbidden any
cross testing between 682 and 239
fearing the consequence of 682 gaining
239's powers and becoming a truly
Unstoppable threat capable of causing an
XK Class end of the world scenario C
zamin Alisha kazimi musadi suggested
kill him with SCP 734 this is an
interesting one SCP 734 also known as
the baby is an anomaly that causes a
painful degenerative disease that
eventually disintegrates the entire body
and kills the victim if they so much has
come into contact with the baby or its
fluids however based on Cross tests with
other similar touch it and die anomalies
like SCP 49 the contagious Crystal we
can probably guess how exactly this
would go down in all likelihood the
baby's anomalous effects would infect
and Destroy large portions of
scp-682's body however at this point 682
would adapt to the threat and begin to
reverse it and heal even worse it's
likely that 682 would steal the ability
for a limited time and become deadly to
the touch Kaden Griffin suggested why
don't you use the dragon slayer to
terminate 682 it has proved itself many
times in fights with lsas SCP 5514 the
the dragon slayer is essentially a giant
fighting robot designed to take down
killer kaijus with its plethora of
state-of-the-art anomalous weapons and
defenses however we'd still argue that
while it could definitely help in
immobilizing 682 during a rampage it
doesn't have much of a chance of
actually killing it let's look at SCP
001 the gate Guardian a supernatural
warrior with a blade hotter than the sun
capable of cleaving atams in half even
he couldn't kill SCP 682 so robotic
approximation with only a fraction of
the gate guardian's power is probably
not going to have any real chance of
killing 682 I'm a chuckster 48 suggested
make it bite its tongue so hard that it
just destroys itself while we can
certainly attest from personal
experience that this really really hurts
we worry that if ever 682 bit its own
tongue really hard it' just drive it
into a state of murderous rage though we
do take a small piece of satisfaction
and knowing its tongue would probably be
in stress for a few minutes afterwards
it's unlikely to wipe out the Beast once
and for all lazyy Ro suggested how about
we just put SCP 682 and 2317 cell SCP
2317 is an old wooden door that
functions as a portal into the domain of
the planet destroying monster known as
the devour of Worlds a being that many
believe is associated with the Scarlet
King and will inevitably escape and
cause an XK Class end of the world
scenario while you may be thinking
perhaps it'll kill 682 it's more likely
that it'll collaborate seeing as they
both want the same thing namely to kill
everyone if you let 682 in chances are
it'll come back through the door with
the Devourer right on its tail then it's
all of our problems guest 12316
suggested drop him in Russia so they can
terminate him the foundation has
technically already tried this they Dro
682 into SCP 3930 a patch of literal
non-existence in Russia that causes
anything that goes inside of it to cease
to exist and afterwards he was fine so
yeah dropping him anywhere in Russia is
probably just going to get a bunch of
innocent Russian civilians killed Myer
said the foundation shouldn't worry
about how to kill him but how to stop
his ability to adapt I would suggest
typing SCP 682 no adaptability juice or
something like that into SCP 294 and
then kill him by any means which should
kill him forever an interesting Theory
but what if he simply adapts to SCP 682
no adaptability juice then we'd really
all be in trouble Mario tgp said give
him a Twitter account he'll be canceled
instantly for his spicy opinions SCP 682
would cancel Twitter itself for not
having opinions that are spicy enough
sorry Jack scp096 still sore about
losing the battle we assume said let him
fight the Queen of England after all
she's Immortal too we definitely think
it would be interesting to see CP 682 go
head-to-head with the Queen of England
based on all the nighting she does we
know that she at least has a sword that
we don't know if that sword is as
powerful as the one wielded by the gate
Guardian but regardless of the outcome
the battle would definitely change
history every history book would simply
read SCP 682 punch the queen everything
else would just be a footnote Noah Cordo
said use SCP 2935 to kill the lizard as
you can see in the video he will die SCP
2935 also known as o death is probably
one of the scariest and deadliest scps
out there it killed an entire alternate
Dimension including an alternate SCP 682
the problem is putting R 682 into 2935
alternate reality could lead to the
destruction of our entire Dimension why
is that because if 682 was somehow able
to return to our world from the world of
2935 it could bring the spirit of death
itself back with it and kill us all in
the process explorando cometto 1
suggested SCP 682 versus lady diatri
while Resident Evil AIDS lady diatri has
certainly captured all of our hearts we
don't think she'll be bringing home the
W on this one lady diatri has a powerful
adaptive ability of her own with a high
resistance to damage impressive
regenerative abilities and a number of
offensive capabilities from huge claws
to a powerful Dragon form however
considering she wasn't able to defeat
Ethan winter she probably wouldn't be
able to defeat SCP 682 either however in
her Dragon form SC SCP 682 May finally
join the rest of us in developing a
crush or is that being crushed anyway
moving on Jonathan pekan suggested just
ask SCP 343 on how to destroy it or even
better ask if he could destroy it it's
an idea so good that the foundation
actually tried it and it went about as
well as you can expect when the SCP
known as God entered the containment
chamber he couldn't even see 682 in
there as though the creature was somehow
totally invisible to him when God
eventually got bored and left they told
him that he was in there to destroy 682
he simply replied he's not one of mine
deal with him yourself interpret that
how you will 12 Escobar Blancas Eddie
Saul suggested they could send him to
area 37 for the Sisters to experiment
with SCP 1765 the sisters are a trio of
terrifyingly powerful reality warpers
that have taken over area 37 and spend
their days tormenting everyone inside
with their Twisted experiments using
them to try to terminate 682 leads to
similar problems with using the witch
child or the devour of Worlds if they
decide to team up rather than fighting
or the sisters take over 682 we'd all be
effectively doomed Kira suggested with
the ants from SCP 743 tear 682 apart the
foundation actually tried this getting
682 to consume chocolate from the SCP
743 Fountain incurring the wrath of its
flesh eating ants however 682 developed
an adaptation that gave it a long ante
eater likee tongue that it then used to
consume the ants faster than they could
consume it and even worse the chocolate
seemed to enhance its regenerative
abilities even more for several days
afterwards L 2222 suggested write the
name in The Death Note great idea we'll
put it into practice as soon as you can
tell us as CP 682s real name it may come
as a surprise but its parents didn't
actually name it the hard to destroy
reptile Steven VI suggested I thought
that maybe we should put him in a giant
blender and then when he's in small
pieces put lava in the blender so it we
incinerate him then put nuclear waste
into the blender and repeat that until
there's no more left of him after the
cooking whisks last time we feel obliged
to include at least one attempt to kill
SCP 682 with oversized kitchen equipment
in every video about him however this
attempt would probably go about as well
as the last one we afraid extreme
physical trauma by conventional means
like burning and dismemberment has never
been successful in the past and the
foundation is extremely hesitant to use
anything Radioactive on the beast in
case it adapts and adds deadly radiation
to its own Arsenal Mr Master IQ
suggested just take away his plot armor
you can pry SCP 682s plot armor from its
cold dead claws and as we've already
learned making those claws cold and dead
seems next to Impossible moving on jc3
suggested hm if anyone can't beat the
undying lizard why not omn man I mean he
did kill all the Guardians of the globe
of course he can kill SCP 682 omn man
from the comic and TV series Invincible
is undeniably a formidable opponent
given he's able to destroy superhero
teams cities and even planets however
one of the few enemies to give omn man a
genuine run for his money is a
Genetically Enhanced Kaiju known as Hail
Mary given that first 682 has taken on
being stronger than omn man like the
gate guardian and lived and second that
omn man has struggled with monsters
before chances are he probably couldn't
permanently kill this one either heany
Hava suggested kill SCP 053 then 682
will be sad and die wow now that's cold
blooded however even if this did work
it's important for you to remember that
it's impossible to actually k SC SCP 053
also known as the child or the little
girl part of her anomalous abilities is
that anyone who attempts to kill her
will themselves immediately die during
the process normally due to a heart
attack so this method would result in a
pile of dead Foundation personnel and no
progress Jerry Jang said mush peanut
butter on it this would definitely work
if 682 had some kind of severe peanut
allergy after all anaphylactic shock is
no laughing matter however in the the
far more likely event that this will
have no effect on SCP 682 you will
likely just die with your hands covered
in peanut butter Andrew Mill suggested
my idea have several Xenomorphs
predators and dollx yes that's the
Doctor Who reference take 682 on once
again in all likelihood this would have
no effect 682 has survived blades and
lasers the Primary Weapons of the
Predators andics and spends the majority
of its life immersed in powerful acid so
the xenomorph would hold no surprises
for it sadly this three-way team up
would be no match for 682 and even if it
did defeat him whoever wins we um well
you know how it goes Mato Quang
suggested maybe just destroy reality
this this might be the thing that
finally kills SCP 682 but considering
it's already survived being thrown into
pure nothingness in Russia it may just
result in it being one of the only
survivors of a full destruction of
reality we on the other hand would all
be killed though in a sense we wouldn't
have to deal with that CP 682 anymore so
maybe that's a type of winning and
finally blind honor suggested would
saitama be a good way to eliminate it he
is one punch man after all of anyone
we've covered in this series saitama
from one punch man would probably be the
most likely to kill SCP 682 especially
if he was taking the battle seriously
after all he has killed Planet
destroying monsters before with barely
any effort the only real question is
whether he could be bothered to come
down to a foundation containment site
and fight it saitama hasn't been known
to be a very motivated guy but of course
like with anything there's the risk that
682 would survive and gain his powers
which would be bad awesome but bad over
50 men and women clad in red robes kneel
before an Unholy altar they chant and
mutter indecipherable words words of
cruelty and Madness of obsession and
sacrilege not long ago these were
regular people computer technicians
teachers plumbers construction workers
accountants this was before they fell
under the ungodly influence of a new
ruler the center of this makeshift place
of worship was once a normal school
gymnasium but it's now the home of a
huge statue a humanoid being wreathed in
tentacles its head is more like a squid
or cuttlefish than anything resembling
an actual human face while he's known to
the cultist as the tentacled god the
Beast they worship is known to the SCP
Foundation as SCP
2662 and he sits in the belly of one of
their expansive containment facilities
locked away from the world but not for
long if his devoted followers have
anything to say about it this is their
God all powerful and unchanging and when
it comes to springing him from
containment no tactic is too vile or
underhanded to get the job done their
mortal leader in high priest a man in a
purple robe calling himself brother
Marsh walks among their crouched forms
he whispers instructions for the great
day of Liberation that's soon to come
providing everyone plays their part it's
a plan months in the making and one that
if it goes off without a hitch could
free their monstrous God into the world
they would strike at the very heart of
their enemy the SCP Foundation when they
least expected and nothing shall stand
in their way how could they lose when
they have a God on their side but why
did all these normal people become
violent zealots for a squidface deity it
all began with a dream to those who
experienced these dreams they felt more
like prophecies premonitions of the
Glorious Horrors to come a red sky
billions dead de and billions more
enslaved a dark silhouette on the
horizon their tentacled God holding
dominion over all at first it just
seemed like a strange nightmare the ones
who experienced it woke up shaken and
Afraid hoping to shake the images from
their mind but they couldn't every night
the nightmare would return they'd see
the images the Red Sky the dead and
Enslaved the tentacled God and after a
while it would come to them even when
they weren't asleep eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes little
by little this scene stopped looking so
hideous and started to look glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe and to experience the
honor of serving him many of them
abandoned their homes and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to to worry that they'd Gone Insane
In Their Eyes they were safer than
they'd ever been they finally had
purpose they were working in service of
something far greater than themselves
the influence of the tentacled god drew
them closer to one another they would
meet in secret exchanging information
from the prophecies their ruler sent to
them in their dreams they worship
together building altars and Idols to
congregate around they performed dark
blood rituals involving human and animal
sacrifice it was when brother Marsh the
anointed one arrived to guide them
towards their true mission that things
kicked into high gear just 3 months
prior brother Marsh had been an office
drone working in data entry for a large
insurance company before the tentacle
God invaded His Thoughts with a simple
message free me and the new world I
create shall be your
playground since then he devoted himself
self completely to the cause quitting
his job and maxing out his credit cards
to help fund his new life's purpose
infiltrating the SCP Foundation and
releasing his inhuman ruler from its
imprisonment that was the single goal he
United the cultist under freedom for the
tentacled God and at long last they had
all the pieces in place to strike they'd
finally gathered the necessary Intel to
subvert the will of the most powerful
secret organization on Earth even the
strongest institution is made of people
and people are weak unlike the almighty
tentacled God people could be broken the
people in question were Kelly Thompson
Sydney levit Jordan broch Dr Juan
Gutierrez and Jillian Larsson Dr Juan
Gutierrez was a researcher with level
three clearance on the site where the
tentacled God was being contained Sydney
levit and Jordan broch were both
security officers charged with verifying
Personnel clearance on site Kelly
Thompson was a member of site
Administration with research
authorization powers and Jillian Larson
was a research assistant who often
collaborated with Dr Gutierrez these
five were the key to getting access to
SCP
2662 and bringing their plan to fruition
normally Personnel dossier on people
working for the foundation were highly
confidential but the devotees of the
tentacled God had their ways they had a
number of computer experts in their
ranks more more than capable of hacking
in and pulling some basic information
off of foundation servers without being
detected for the other information they
needed they turn to some good
oldfashioned torture which is often the
most effective method when you need some
quick results of course while the Colts
grip on sanity may have been a little
tenuous they weren't stupid while
Gathering their Intel they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were
up against SCP 2662 was being held in a
humanoid containment cell and guarded by
on-site Task Force Town 9 better known
as the belligerent bodyguards these
aren't lazy dut chopping M cops these
are a heavily trained heavily armed
fighting force though the cultist had
one thing that these Foundation soldiers
didn't the element of surprise for
everything to go off perfectly brother
Marsh's plans would have to be executed
within a single day and they were
already on the clock T 9 had been
charged with tracking down any new SCP
2662 Colts and dismantling them and
brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled God then they need
to strike quickly and with overwhelming
Force the SCP 2662 worshippers were able
to secure the addresses of the five key
Foundation personnel and station members
outside each of them including one who
could realistically imitate each they
waited for night to fall and broke into
each of their homes as they slapped What
followed was a sequence of Ruthless and
efficient murders done in the cause of
freeing their God Dr Gutierrez was shot
in the head while he slept Sydney levit
and Jordan broch were both stabbed to
death before either even realized what
was happening Thompson who'd gotten up
to use the bathroom went down in the
hail of machine gun fire Jillian Larson
had seen that mask Figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs
entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies
imaginable were murdered in their homes
by nothing more than regular
humans so far brother Marsh's plan had
gone perfectly with all five key
personnel murdered within a 2minute
period next the selected doppelgangers
stole clothes from their victim closets
and were handed the correct Forge
documentation the next morning each
replacement began their Journeys to the
site where the tentacled God was being
contained while the rest of the cult
armed themselves in preparation for
their own part in the plan nobody at the
foundation seemed to notice anything a
miss when the five arrived on site when
you work for the SCP Foundation more
mental energy is devoted to following
the rules that keep you alive than two
memorizing the faces of all your
co-workers and each one SLI neatly into
position disappearing into the
familiarity of office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the belligerent bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled God
would be another thing entirely that's
where the rest of the cult would come
into play heavily armed with whatever
Firearms they could get their hands on
the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother Marsh included
would attack the containment site headon
in the in the ensuing chaos the five
cultists who had already infiltrated the
site could take advantage of the
distraction and break into the
containment chamber it was perfect they
launched their attack from the outside
and from within when brother Marsh
declared that the time was right the
assault began a legion of gun wielding
culas seemed to Spring out of nowhere
and started shooting up the warehouse
that was a front for the containment
site the site quickly mobilized guards
and task force members to take on the
sudden R and just as brother Marsh had
anticipated the site director called on
the majority of town 9 to help repel the
violent cultist from their perimeter
Town n obeyed leaving three task force
members behind a guard SCP 2662
containment chamber they expected to be
guarding the cell from rampaging
religious zealots seeking an audience
with their God what they didn't expect
was a group of five Foundation employees
walking right up to them and opening
fire killing two found nine members and
taking the third as hostage while the
war was being waged outside the
infiltrators had found the tentacle Gods
containment cell in the lowrisk humanoid
Ward their hostage insisted that using
him wouldn't give them any leverage the
rest of his team would neutralize the
whole group him included if that's what
it took to stop them the infiltrators
explained that using him as leverage was
never their intention he wasn't a
hostage at all he was a sacrifice the
cultists of the tentacled god detonated
explosives creating a hole in the wall
and finally giving them access to their
deity they climbed through and gazed
upon him in awe there stood SCP
2662 twice as tall as a regular man with
10 huge tentacles emerging from its back
in their months of envisioning this
creature they pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators what what they
certainly didn't expect was to see the
tentacled god hunched over a computer
screen still God's work in mysterious
ways so they stuck to the plan and began
chanting they pulled out a sacrificial
dagger and began sacrificing their
captured Town n member it was at this
point that SCP 2662 turned and saw what
they were doing with a look of pure
horror he rose up from his computer his
headphones getting caught as he did so
he told them to go away that he didn't
want them here and that the murdering
people in his bedroom like this was
inconsiderate and disgusting the cultist
became even more confused why wasn't
their God accepting their offerings what
were they doing wrong they tried more
chanting and painting Arcane symbols on
the floor in blood but this just seemed
to make the creature angrier he told
them in a tone more fitting for a
teenage boy than a love crafy and God to
just leave him alone so he could play
his video games this was seriously not
cool the cultists were baffled they told
the tentacled god that they were there
to free him he replied that he didn't
need saving that crazy stalkers like
them were why he turned himself into the
foundation in the first place before the
ctist infiltrators could get another
word in the remaining members of town 9
stormed into the containment cell and
gunned them down with surgical Precision
the war outside was already over brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the firefight Town 9
didn't look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662 cell this was a common
occurrence
Unfortunately they had to deal with an
attempted cult Invasion every few months
because SCP 2662 is main anomalous
ability is inspiring violent Cults who
relentlessly track down and worship it
with Arcane and bloodthirsty rituals the
problem is 2662 doesn't do this
consciously and definitely doesn't like
the results that's why he's under the
voluntary care of the SCP Foundation who
keeps him amused with video games and
reading material while fending off the
deranged Colts who try to invade and
abduct him following the termination of
the devotees of the tentacled God just
one of many Colts who'd broken into 2662
containment cell the remaining Town n
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before some like this
happened again SCP 2662 cell was
repaired and the foundation returned to
its task of seeking out wouldbe cult
emancipator because for the SCP
Foundation it's not always about the
anomaly that's being kept in containment
but what's being kept out please good
sir I beseech you as a man of science
nay as a man of reason you mustn't
stifle my research at this critical
juncture you have no idea how close I am
to finding a cure for this blasted
pestilence I need only a handful of live
subjects to complete my research the
plague doctor's emphatic pleas fell on
deaf ears as a stoneface researcher took
notes on his latest pontifications the
doctor whom these claws had reduced so
rudely to a mere number SCP 049 banged
his gloved fist up against the wall and
to think he once thought of these men as
intellectual equals fellow Travelers on
the road to Scientific Enlightenment
what a positively sick joke before the
doctor got another chance to appeal for
his right to experiment the researcher
left him alone once more a truly sad
State of Affairs nobody appreciated a
true scientist in this day and age it
was sure to be another day of
languishing alone in his cell wishing he
had the capacity to do more so so he was
surprised as anyone when the alarm
started going off and the door of his
cell swung open automatically the plague
doctor stepped out of his cell and into
the Hall where many other humanoid
anomalies were roaming confused as to
why they'd been suddenly released what
was happening as it turned out what was
happening was one of the most brutal
chaos Insurgency raids the staff of site
19 had ever seen it had been planned
immaculately you see guards rotate
semi-regularly at site 19 due to the
high press nature of the job lots of
deaths and mental breakdowns as you
probably correctly predicted even the
administrative staff of the SCP
Foundation are only human well mostly
anyway so they're not immune to little
oversights here and there and it's in
those oversights that expertly trained
chaos Insurgency infiltration agents
make their living no less than 15 of
them had been working undercover in site
19 for just over 2 weeks and they did a
fine job of lowering the the
metaphorical drawbridge for a heavily
armed Invasion Force the guards who
weren't plants were quickly murdered by
the infiltrators and even some of the
on-site task forces were quickly
overwhelmed and gunned down by the high
Precision rifles of the chaos
insurgency's finest while the
frontliners were distracted by the
sudden assault the infiltrators found
their way to the site security control
room and massacred everyone inside
opening every single door in the site
was as simple as putting in a few stolen
key codes and flipping a few carefully
remembered switches consequently while
Foundation agents and cast Insurgency
mercenaries clashed Sabers high priority
anomalies like SCP 049 simply wandered
the facility watching the Calamity
unfold within the foundation was beset
on all sides shot at by heavily armed
maniacs and attacked from within by the
numerous roaming anomalous entities that
were eager to get their hands on
Foundation Personnel definitely not an
ideal situation to say the least the
plague doctor only had one thing on his
mind though H this definitely won't do
my research any good unless I can escape
and find my way to a suitable laboratory
ooh now there is an idea but his
scientific fantasies were soon
interrupted by a chaos Insurgency
Soldier swinging the butt of his M4
carbine into his Aven exos skull with a
supremely unpleasant crack the doctor
was Dazed by it moment arily the pain
coming at him like a Thunderclap but the
Insurgent never got the chance to take
another swing before the Insurgent could
do anything the plague doctor lunged out
with practice speed grasping him by the
throat immediately everything went black
and the Insurgent limp corpse collapsed
to the ground s him right the doctor
internally mused soldiers attacking
Medics is violating even the most basic
rules of gentlemanly warfare then
another flash of immense pain has a
different rifle butt collided with the
back of his head the doctor fell to one
knee feeling dizzy but before he could
retaliate he felt the two sharp prongs
of a cattle prod pressing up against his
neck the Sudden Rush of electricity
surged through his neck sending his
muscles into a wave of involuntary
spasms the insurgents crowding around
him chimed in with their own agonizing
cattle prods relentlessly shocking him
until the flashes of white hot pain soon
became an oppressive blanket of total
dark even on his most canang days the
SCP Foundation had never treated him
like this when he eventually came to he
was still in darkness standing upright
with high-tech shackles holding every
limb in place it was beyond
uncomfortable for the poor plague doctor
but it succeeded in the task of keeping
him under control he couldn't move an
inch there were muffled voices beyond
the dark beyond the confines of this new
containment the modulated gas mask
voices of insurgents and something else
faintly accented oddly familiar but he
couldn't quite place it soon the voices
were replaced by another sound the
grinding of crowbars Levering Nails out
of cheap wood with a creaking tumble a
rectangle of bright light opened up in
front of him populated by a number of
silhouettes on either side were chaos
insurgents in familiar tactical Garb and
in between them stood a tall
well-groomed man with an expensive
looking purple smoking jacket and a
pencil mustache for a few fractions of a
second his face was a portrait of
excitement but as he took in the sight
of the plague doctor standing before him
all the joy drained from his snoody
countenance what the hell am I looking
at here the man in the smoking jacket
said the doctor indignant had such a
response from the man who' presumably
ordered his assault rasped a man of
science good sir the man in the smoking
jacket ignored him and continued to
berate the chaos insurgents with an odd
level of confidence for someone
reprimanding trained coldblooded Killers
I wanted SCP 650 the startling statue
not this clownish renfair cosplayer what
the hell did I pay you Ruffian for I was
told you chaos insurgents were the very
best at this and for your FY price I
expect Excellence the rant continued
much like this leaving everyone in
attendance the insurgents the plague
doctor feeling thoroughly exhausted by
him and unable to do anything about it
you see this wasn't just any chaos
Insurgency client Your Average tinpot
dictator or arms dealer you know the typ
this was the one and only Pascal Legette
one of the most famous or rather
Infamous anarch collectors in the game
he'd been a founding Person of Interest
for years due to his dealings with the
chaos Insurgency and Marshall Carter and
dark limited all to the end of expanding
his Anar collection but his vast wealth
and connections had always shielded him
from Foundation probes for those
unfamiliar with the subculture an art
short for anomalous art is ex exactly
what it sounds like artistic projects
with anomalous properties to give it
that extra kick one of the most popular
groups of Interest dealing in an art is
the iconic are we cool yet which
incidentally had recently excommunicated
Pascal Legette for being an exceedingly
wealthy uptight Square who really didn't
represent the collective's rebellious
ethos and considering his response was
to pay the chaos Insurgency to raid site
19 for a few pieces for his own private
collection costing him millions of
dollars in both groups many lives it was
safe to say he wasn't taking it well
look we got you that other Statue and
that thing killed four of our best guys
so how about we just call it even said
one of the insurgents I'm sure you can
have fun with bird brain here too Pascal
tutted and reluctantly dismissed The
Hired Guns having the plague doctor here
definitely wasn't ideal especially
considering he wanted to host the
ultimate an art exhibition to put are we
cool yet worthless somu deu magnif to
shame but he would make do with with
what he had perhaps he could say that
049 was a commentary on the everpresent
nature of disease in Mankind's life and
our forever archaic approach to it yes
yes that would do nicely needless to say
the plague doctor was infuriated by all
this the violence against his person the
kidnapping the disrespect and most of
all the interruption to his precious
research especially considering how
close he'd got to finding a cure for the
pestilence but instead he was soon
spirited by a legion of heavily armed
Goons from his wooden box to a glass one
in one of lett's many opulent hallways
there were other glass cases on either
side of him and more on the other side
of the hall all too reinforced for the
plague doctor to even smash through it
on his own damn it Legette own private
an art exhibition probably wedged
between his oversized dining room and
his Jewel en crusted crapper
occasionally Pascal himself would jaunt
down the hallway to gaze upon his new
stolen anarch pieces and of course the
plague doctor would try his best to
reason with him I am a patient man M
leet but this is simply barbaric by what
right do you imprison me here is your
intention to deprive the world the
entire human race of my valuable medical
breakthroughs could you live with that
on your conscience good sir there was
never any meaningful response the plague
doctors soon learned that Pascal Legette
didn't like his art interactive it was
simply meant to languish away in a glass
box being watched being p mely looked at
those chaos Insurgency louts hadn't even
bothered to bring his notebook or
medical bag so he was without the tools
to even perform his experiments as
loathed as he was to admit it this was
even worse than being locked up by the
SCP Foundation but all this wasn't
entirely unfamiliar there was something
in the glass box across from the plague
doctor that he vaguely recognized back
from sight 19 he'd never seen it up
close but he'd heard researchers
speaking about it and even SE seen a few
pictures and such a strange construction
it was a peculiar halfhazard sculpture
made from concrete rebar and spray paint
quite ugly in this humble doctor's
opinion but there was something oddly
entrancing about it and for reasons
beyond the doctor's recollection four of
Legette men stood around the glass box
in where it was being stored always
watching the men were frequently
switched in and out as though they were
watching in shifts always fixing Gaze on
its peculiar malformed body maybe it was
all the electrical shocks and knocks to
the head but he just couldn't remember
why Pascal was having the piece so
carefully observed but he knew on some
Primal level that the secret to this
would perhaps be the key to his own
Escape if only he could remember still
time passed Pascal drifted in and out
sometimes with guests the plague doctor
had learned not to speak these animals
could not be reasoned with as a
scientist he would instead carefully
observe until his observations bore
fruit he noticed that Pascal's guests
all people who looked equally as wealthy
and pompous as Pascal himself all seemed
to look right over him and instead focus
on the ugly statue across the hall still
forever observed by any four of Pascal's
men some of them looked actively nervous
just being in its presence curious the
plague doctor made a mental note of this
just as he did when Pascal gave his
guest a reassuring pat on the shoulder
and told them please calm yourself it's
harmless while my Personnel are keeping
an eye on it little by little the plague
doctor's memories of his Infamous
neighbor had begun to return he knew
what he must do to escape now all he
needed to do was wait for the perfect
moment soon enough Pascal's Mansion was
filled with a bevy of anart snobs from
hither or and yarn a private sware to
show off his new collection they
wandered the halls in three-piece
Tuxedos and designer ball room dresses
sipping champagne from imported Crystal
all such lovely refined High Society
people and if the good doctor's plan
went off as he intended they would all
be such lovely refined High Society
corpses the plague doctor waited until
mercifully he and the four members of
personnel watching the sculpture were
the only ones left in the hallway he'd
been so good so patient that none of the
men guarding the sculpture at present
had ever heard him make a noise he was
so invisible to them that in all
likelihood they probably didn't even
notice he could make a sound and that
worked for his purposes just fine though
in any case if he wanted this to work he
would need to time his plan perfectly
even a fraction of a second out of place
and the whole thing would have dire
consequences still the doctor was still
a Frenchman at heart and as a Frenchman
he knew he would rather die nobly in the
process of Escape than remain captured
by this worthless buffoon he'd be sure
to to take as many of these men down
with him in the process as he was able
the plague doctor exhaled deeply drawing
a lung full of air then bellowed as loud
as he possibly could the sudden
unexpected noise was so shocking that it
jogged the four Watchers almost
reflexively to turn and look at him and
in the split second that they did the
plague doctor closed his eyes in the
dark time seemed to move slower perhaps
due to the doctor's Keen Focus
cultivated over many a century he
listened care y to the sequence of
sounds glass shattering four choked
gasps in sequence four brutal crunches
then Nan later more glass shattering the
plague doctor's eyes snapped open just
in time just as predicted the sculpture
being entirely unobserved had smashed
through its glass case murdering all
four members of personnel by snapping
their necks and then smashed through his
own glass case to do the same to him the
plague doctor had cut it so close in
fact that he opened open his eyes to the
face of the sculpture staring into his
own its concrete limbs wrapped around
his neck very good timing indeed with a
sigh of relief the plague doctor slipped
out of the sculpture's concrete grasp
and backed down the hallway keeping his
gaze fixed on the sculpture the entire
time he had heard it decimate Pascal's
men he certainly didn't fancy undergoing
the same fate the second the plague
doctor backed around the corner
rendering the sculpture or as the SCP
Foundation called it SCP 173 out of
sight he could hear terrified screaming
coming from the other end of the hall he
was not a sadistic man but the plague
doctor would be lying if he told you he
didn't take just a little bit of
pleasure in hearing that sound somewhere
else in the vast Mansion of Pascal
Legette the sculpture was slaughtering
its way through servants and party
guests while the plague doctor searched
for some kind of exit anyone who dared
get in his way was given a Swift and
merciless Touch of death sending their
body unceremoniously to the ground
anyone in his way was preventing him
from finding a cure for the pestilence
and thus endangering countless lives it
was of course regrettable to have to
kill anyone but some sacrifices must be
made for the greater good of mankind
well it's not necessarily always
regrettable per se on his way out while
the murderous Rampage of SCP 173 seemed
to distract anyone of note the plague
doctor just so happened to encounter a
fleeing Pascal Legette hoping to find
some kind of Escape himself it seemed
that now fate was on his side once more
to have his Jailer right here in the
palm of his hand would be such a perfect
Parting Gift funnily enough Pascal was
far more talkative to him now he rattled
off a rapid fire series of threats
bribes and pleas claiming in the end
that he never meant any harm he was the
one who freed the plague doctor from the
SCP Foundation they were on the same
side here all this was for the art no
offense was ever intended Pascal Legette
simply lived for art then die for it
good sir the plague doctor said and with
a single touch Pascal's eyes rolled up
into the back of his head and he fell to
the ground dead it was one of the few
non-scientific deaths that he felt truly
no guilt for after some time searching
the screams around the rest of the
Mansion eventually went silent that did
wonders for his focus it didn't take
long for the plague doctor to locate an
exit a fine mahogany door with a
elaborate adornments befitting a man as
Gody as Pascal and began strolling
towards it his chest swollen with pride
in a sense of accomplishment then he
blinked and a few feet in front of him
stood the sculpture it was there so
suddenly that the plague doctor fell
backwards in shock but he devoted
everything to keeping an eye on that
monstrosity with everyone else in the
Mansion presumably dead at this point it
had now come back for him it stood there
staring silently ready to exact the
terrible price for freeing it as as soon
as the doctor dared to Blink the plague
doctor began crawling backwards down the
hall just wanting to put some distance
between himself and the sculpture as the
seconds passed he could feel his eyes
drying out until the inevitable blink
the sculpture was standing right in
front of him now gazing down almost
mocking it had closed the distance so
quickly if the plague doctor blinked
again he was sure that his eyes would
never open again all it had to do was
wait as the seconds passed and the
doctor began to feel his eyes dry dying
up again that subtle sting quickly grew
into a nagging pain that could not be
denied sooner or later he was going to
have to bang the front door flew open
and in an instant the hallway was filled
with heavily armed troops all wearing
the familiar black and gray of the SCP
Foundation the plague doctor had never
been so relieved to see the organization
that had kept him locked up for so many
decades for once they'd saved him from
something even worse of course the
sculpture didn't say anything but the
disappointment of losing that one more
victim seemed to radiate off of it like
a lingering bad smell the plague doctor
willingly gave himself up and heavy
machinery was brought in to pick up SCP
173 with the help of the iPods to make
sure it didn't try any funny business in
transit Pascal had gotten away with his
Shady dealings for years but the Brazen
attack he funded against site 19 was now
enough for the foundation to track him
down when his corpse was found in the
halls of his own home with no obvious
cause of death we can happily tell you
that nobody was disappointed by the
evening the plague doctor was happy to
be back in his cell his research could
continue here and in time he knew that
the Personnel of the SCP Foundation
would listen to reason and comply with
his demands after all science Marches On
regardless of who chooses to march with
it but he would forever feel a little
nervous in sight 19 after that knowing
the concrete monster he was sharing the
building with he hoped that if ever
there was was another Containment Breach
involving that thing that it didn't feel
like paying him a visit for Old Time
sake the whole earth seemed to rumble
beneath him as Carlos Garcia stood there
standing up at the hulking shadowy Mass
towering over him his knees were shaking
and sweat was running down his face but
he clenched his jaw and stayed put
Furious voices hurled abuse at him from
all angles the stench of gasoline and
wood smoke filled the air as the
rumbling grew louder and louder gripping
the camcorder tightly Carlos pointed it
straight up at the enormous excavator
that was belching out smoke just feet
away from him angry men in high
visibility jackets hung off the sides of
it making hand gestures at him and even
throwing rocks but Carlos found much to
his surprise that his filming hand was
steady he panned the lens across the
view in front of him excavators
lumberjacks standing on Cut Down tree
trunks as thick as motorcycles and then
up into the Lush canopies of the Amazon
rainforest with its rich dark green
leaves dense knotted Vines colorful
fruits and terrified ecosystem colorful
birds watched the scene with nervous
eyes ready to take off at a moment's
notice all of the larger animals had
either run away or been killed long
before he showed up Carlos swung the
camcorder back down to the mercenaries
chopping down his beloved rainforest and
jabbed a finger at them you will not put
your axe to the trunk of one more tree
without first cutting me down sick of
waiting the workmen climbed back into
their vehicles and started revving their
engines it was all for show Carlos told
himself that's all it was they were just
trying to scare him but it was working
he was scared the excavator in front of
him crept slowly forward with tires that
were taller than he was a foot away 6 in
away and then an inch away Carlos closed
his eyes and Reed himself to be run over
but the pain never came a whining
chewing noise came from the engine as if
the vehicle was suddenly trapped on
something unable to turn its Wheels
Carlos opened his eyes and tried to peer
around the edge of the vehicle to see
what was going on at the back there was
a new note in the voices of the workmen
around him they didn't seem so angry
anymore more fearful Carlos went to take
a step to see what was going on but his
foot caught and he was trapped looking
down he saw that he had somehow managed
to Lodge his foot beneath a small tree
rout he triying to pull himself free but
the grip tightened all of a sudden the
roots wound tightly around his boots
instantly crushing his foot and breaking
every bone inside of it Carlos screamed
but through the dullness of Terror that
was filling his mind he realized no one
else would hear him because they were
all too busy screaming themselves the
root wasn't just tightening around
around his foot now it was pulling him
dragging him the dirt parted around his
crushed foot as the root dragged him
down into the Earth it wasn't that the
ground was swallowing him it was that
the root was pulling so hard that the
ground broke apart around his body the
pressure was unbelievable as first his
ankle then his knee and then his hip
went under he felt the bones in his
pelvis crunching and breaking as his
other leg was forced into an unnatural
split
it would be good to tell you that Carlos
Garcia had a quick death from that point
that he felt no pain as his body was
wrenched down into the Earth but no he
died very slowly in a tremendous amount
of fear and pain as his lungs steadily
filled up with Earth and his bones
splintered and crunched one by one one
of the most admirable traits of the
human race has always been our ability
to find a home anywhere from the Inuit
people living in the Arctic Circle all
the way through to the ancient Egyptians
building colossal pyramids in the middle
of arid deserts Humanity always finds a
way to make a home anthropologists can
look all over the world and find traces
of human settlements virtually anywhere
one of the remaining Bastion where
tribal populations can still exist and
flourish is the Amazon rainforest life
can be difficult and fiercely
competitive but the rich fertile ground
and abundance of food sources have meant
that the Amazon has always been home to
small human settlements that is why
researchers were so perplexed by the
existence of a dark spot within the
rainforest after Decades of work not one
trace of human life has been found
within this area for good reason for a
very good reason Foundation agent
Natalie Richards made her way quickly
down the stairs spiraling downwards and
downwards she had never much enjoyed the
Descent something about waking up in the
morning and knowing that she would wind
up back down here again went beyond the
usual Monday blues it was more Insidious
she had barely slept all week it wasn't
just the sticky heat of the barracks at
the Paragon South America forward
operating site that kept her awake it
was the paranoia she would just lie
there in her bed experiencing these
delusions that at any point a root would
shoot up out of the ground and wrap
itself around her neck it never happened
of course their accommodations had been
built high up suspended among the trees
away from the site to mitigate any risk
but still it would always get worse when
it was her turn on the observation deck
down and down she descended through the
tower feeling that horrible pressurizing
feeling that tells you you're going
further underground the air she was
breathing down here was filtered by
enormous top-of-the-line systems that
made sure the air within the tower was
clean and fresh there was an entire
department dedicated to the filtration
system set up in each of the four towers
and yet she couldn't help imagining that
tendrils of fog creeping through the
vents to get to her suddenly she was
there on the observation deck she hadn't
had time to brace herself so the view
even though she had seen it dozens of
times before punched her right in the
stomach and left her feeling dizzy on
the other side of the glass was a void
the research team had told her that it
was 53 km across at its whitest point
and 42 km at its deepest those kinds of
numbers meant nothing to her the reality
was that it was Darkness a rotten Abyss
open and unending she was in Tower
Charlie one of four observation towers
suspended upside down from the roof of
the cavern at the bottom of the tower
what usually would have been the top was
the search light its beam cut steadily
through the abyss like a lighthouse in
the dead of night the beam drifted
through empty space the only way you
could even tell it was lit up was the
slight Haze in the air suddenly the
search light found its Target just a
branch at first nothing thicker than a
car snaking its way to join with another
and another growing thicker by
multitudes each time until suddenly the
light was shining on the trunk 380 m in
diameter 9.2 km tall the Colossal tree
hung upside down from the roof of the
Void dangling into the abyss Natalie
Richards gulped and tried to breathe
deeply so as not to lose her balance it
was her job to stare at this tree for
the next 3 hours she felt sick SCP
6666 is a colossal Botanical entity that
can be found near the coordinates 4° 51
minutes 29.4 seconds South by 67° 44
minutes 12.6 seconds west in the Amazon
rainforest research has been ongoing for
several years to fully map and
understand the scale of both the tree
itself and the void in which it inhabits
project Paragon was instituted in an
attempt to understand and one day
contain the growth of this entity above
ground an exclusion Zone has been set up
covering the area where the roots of
this tree have grown through to the
surface a 1 km buffer has been
established just outside of the
circumference with a heavily armed
security presence patrolling it at all
times unfortunately due to the nature of
SCP
6666 this buffer zone has to be moved on
a normal weekly basis while samples
taken from this SCP seem to indicate
that it is totally dead organically
speaking the root system still possesses
a degree of autonomy being able to move
and grow at rates unseen in typical
plant species the roots are capable of
breaking through the surface and
constricting organic life living above
primarily targeting humans but also
targeting buildings vehicles and
Machinery it is no wonder then that
there is no trace of any human
settlements either contemporary or
historical anywhere near SCP
6666 she knew that the foundation has
been at a loss for Progress over the
prior few months their equipment and
resources were deteriorating faster than
they were making progress with their
research no one had been down to the
floor yet they were all too afraid to
descending down through the void agent
Richard saw something that made her
heart drop out of the Gap in the trunk
of SCP
666 emerged a hand it clung to the bark
with enormous fingers straining and
pulling as the entity dragged itself out
from its Hiding Place arm after arm
emerged with one carrying a spear that
must have been 20 M long five arms in
total clung to the tree as SCP 6666 daa
surveyed the vehicle flying past it the
entity didn't swipe at the VTO it didn't
do anything to attack it but it just
watched before slowly turning its face
towards agent Richards in the
observation tower it had six eyes
arranged into columns running down the
length of its face it had no nose no
mouth and no ears but it saw her it saw
her even better than she could see it
she felt Panic rising in her chest
meanwhile the research team and the VTO
checked their equipment one more time
they had been outfitted with a brand new
set of custom pressurized insertion
suits but they weren't stupid nothing
was 100% safe from reach and having
studied the fog down here for month
after month they knew just how deadly it
could be if if there was even the
slightest contamination down and down
the craft descended kilometer after
kilometer through utter Blackness until
through the front window they were able
to see a thick layer of fog coating the
basement of the cabin the lead
researcher stood at the front of the VTO
and gave them one more briefing
emphasizing the importance of moving
slowly and safely not touching anything
that could compromise the Integrity of
their suits and making sure to collect
as many physical samples as possible
possible to take back up to the surface
for study agent Richard stared at the
demon in front of her even through the
very enforced glass she could hear the
low rumbling of its voice as it spoke to
her researchers have been trying to
understand what language it was for
years now but with no luck it was either
so ancient or so alien that it was
beyond their ability to translate The
Entity had a name however from speaking
to researchers on Project Paragon
adjacent to SCP 484
they have been able to name the creature
the demon Hector one of four primeval
entities originating from a long since
lost near human civilization millions of
years old at least who knows it may even
predate the existence of Earth entirely
of course we can't simply mention the
concept of four primeval demons without
telling you a little bit about the other
three some of which you might even
recognize one of them known as SCP 2254
to the SCP Foundation is also known as
the demon lir much like Hector lahir is
a six-eyed being of immense power
presiding over his own domain he is
invisible to the naked eye and spends
his free time influencing the minds of
human beings when he's not impregnating
them with fleshing masses next Comes The
Entity known to the SCP Foundation as
SCP
484b also known as the demon Lancelot
once a brave knight of King sarus VII
Bon apolon before being corrupted this
immensely powerful being resides in SCP
4840 the flying city of otop
Papadopoulos and rounding out this Elite
group of mysterious demonic entities
comes SCP
6765 DD also known as the demon ogier a
horrific cloaked entity that sits a top
of Throne of blood it's widely believed
these four entities were cursed by an
unknown and immensely powerful
phological being long ago doomed to hide
in ancient places and live until they
fulfill the their true purpose playing a
part in some known event that will
someday compromise all of mankind and
now agent Richards was face to face with
one quarter of the Apocalypse agent
Richards stared as the demon Hector
spoke to her dozens of kilometers below
the VTO touched down in the fog as soon
as the deployment doors opened the thick
gas filled the aircraft obscuring their
Vision turning on their helmet cameras
the researchers stepped out into the
unknown as their live feeds were watched
by their colleagues on the surface
smooth Stone Surfaces covered with
etchings swam into view some kind of
ancient language carved into stone the
remnants of some early South American
civilization no the researchers on the
surface knew immediately that what they
were looking at was far too advanced far
too old was it was it even human at all
a scream filled the control room a
breach in a researcher suit the fog that
he breathed in contained just a few
particles set the neurons in his brain
on fire before shutting down his nervous
system entirely in a matter of seconds
the rest of the researchers all ran back
to the v2l in fear but the fog around
them was so dense that they couldn't
find it anywhere it could have been 3 ft
away from them and they would have never
even known one by one the researchers in
the foggy Forest dropped dead on the
surface the research team side enclosed
the video feeds there was a reason
they'd sent them down with live cameras
no one had really expected them to
return and all the while agent Natalie
Richards stood trembling and watching as
the demon Hector hung from the upside
down tree and chanted at her in his
impossible language she didn't care what
any of the botanists said this tree was
not dead the demon Reed its Spear and
leaped at her Diego had only just found
his footing when it gave out underneath
him again crashing to the ground he
threw both arms over his head just in
time to protect his skull from the rain
of Boulders that came down past him they
grazed his arms and Jarred painfully
against his muscles but it was better
than having them hit him in the head
without a moment to spare Diego got
straight up to his feet and continued
running back down the trail he had been
trying to follow the ground shifted and
lurched in all directions under him
threatening to throw off his balance at
any moment having lived in Chile his
whole life he had gotten used to
earthquakes but he had never been in the
center of one like this the problem was
that the trail he had been following to
get up here was disappearing fast as the
dust swirled into the air and boulders
Landing all around him he just had to
keep running in this direction and hope
for the best there weren't any other
options but suddenly he found himself
running uphill stumbling forwards Diego
tried desperately to get his bearings he
had spent the previous 3 hours hiking up
the mountains so how was it that now
that he had turned around round and gone
back he was still going uphill it was
almost as if the ground was changing
shape beneath him as he ran dust filled
his lungs as he tried to wipe it away
from his burning eyes yes the ground was
definitely going uphill but it felt
almost as if it was lifting itself up
beneath him as if some tectonic plates
were grinding together creating a new
Mountain beneath his feet Diego lurched
unsteadily and grabbed the nearest rock
to keep his balance feeling the ground
lifting higher and higher beneath him
then all of a sudden the cloud of dust
broke and he was in fresh air Rising
ever higher into the sky the Andy
mountains stabbed out of the clouds all
around him cutting beautiful shapes
across the Horizon he felt his own
Mountain steadily growing taller than
any of them he dropped down on all
floors and clutched at the ground in
Terror as he tried his best to take in
the shape of what he was now standing
upon
how far would you go to prevent a cosmic
level disaster it's one thing to save
your friends and family from an armed
murderer it's another thing to fight for
your country in a world war we can even
just about imagine what it means to
fight for our planet to save our species
from climate change to save our world
from a meteorite but what would a cosmic
disaster look like a Calamity so Broad
in scale that it surpasses our ability
to even perceive the threat we could
Point our most advanced telescope into
deep space and look straight down the
middle of it and never know it was even
there and if that threat was not simply
to the survival of humanity or planet
Earth but to the survival of existence
itself how far would we go to prevent it
what cruel and inhumane measures would
you take to have such a threat or better
yet how many people would you kill to
save the world world this debate is
Raging right now as you sit here and
watch this video not among the
foundation but between two scps so Grand
in scale and so advanced in nature that
the foundation has no option but to sit
and listen as the pair debate what to do
with the human race SCP
468-1 was not difficult to discover once
it started moving in fact it was almost
impossible to ignore earthquakes have
been tearing across South America for
centuries destroying homes taking the
lives of innocent people and
fundamentally changing the shape of our
planet itself what most people do not
realize however is that the fault line
running through the Andes mountain range
has actually largely been dormant during
this period the source of the
earthquakes has come from something far
more mysterious our innocent hiker Diego
had been spending the week walking among
the Andes when the earthquake struck you
would be forgiven for assuming as die
ego did that the ground Rising beneath
his feet was a new Mountain forming as
the tectonic plates clashed together but
the Staggering reality of the situation
was that he found himself hiking along
the back of SCP
468-1 as the creature raised its head
into the air Diego saw the head of a
serpent lifting several kilometers away
from him its body stretched and wound
its way through the mountain range
filling the valleys and running beneath
his feet the scale of SCP
468-1 is hard to convey measuring over
500 km in length this serpent is longer
than most US states with a 20 km width
standing on the back of it quite
literally feels like standing on a
mountain range for context The Horizon
at sea level is about 4.8 km away so
multiply that by four and you'll get a
sense of just how wide this thing is
even small movements from this SCP are
enough to trigger continent wide
earthquakes with tremors being felt all
the way around the world upon the
initial discovery of this SCP the
foundation was enabled to determine why
it remains dormant for such long periods
and seems to only awaken sporadically
and for brief periods of time that was
until SCP
45682 was discovered it is little wonder
that the second serpent took so long to
be found its body is comprised almost
entirely of water sand algae and steam
it does not show up on Sonar scans and
is incredibly difficult to detect in the
water even visually its form is Loosely
defined while stormant with broadly
similar measurements to SCP
468-1 this serpent roams the South
Pacific Ocean any Marine creatures that
swim into the scp's body find themselves
undergoing beneficial mutations crabs
grow extra Pinchers Bottom Feeders grow
larger mouths and and sharks find
themselves developing heightened senses
and even extra hearts these marine
animals seem to undergo virtually no
distress and are free to exit and
re-enter the scp's body at any point
initially SCP 4568 D2 was believed to be
the peaceful one of the pair both
serpents seem to become active at the
same time while on land SCP
468-1 would wreck havoc with magnitude 7
earthquakes in major metropolitan areas
the sea Serpent's function was less well
understood employing resonant
frequencies and vibrations this SCP was
able to give its watery body a distinct
form as it rose up from the ocean and
towered above the waves in order to
maintain its shape and control its
movements this SCP employed a huge
amount of energy however the foundation
quickly observed that it was rarely able
to maintain its form for very long as
soon as the sea serpent Rose out of the
water its mountainous twin would begin
to move sending Tremors around the world
that disrupted the frequency needed for
SCP
45682 to remain animate exhausted and
unable to maintain its shape the sea
serpent would fall into another period
of dorcy gliding lazily through the
oceans but this dorcy suited the
foundation without the constant seismic
Tremors researchers could work fast two
operating bases were set up to monitor
each as SCP two mirrored bases with
mirrored teams in constant communication
with one another as soon as one team
made a discovery it was conveyed to the
others and vice versa one operating base
was set up high in the Andes Mountains
specifically designed to be as
earthquake proof as possible capable of
withstanding earthquakes up to 9.9
magnitude meanwhile in the South Pacific
Ocean an underwater Research Center was
built just above the seabed with regular
vessels drifting out into the unknown to
gather whatever data they could about
the great scps several early findings
stood out firstly SC SCP
468-1 appeared to have a very different
internal structure from its twin
researchers initially assumed that the
creature would be largely composed of
Earth minerals and rock as its exterior
appearance suggested however scans of
its body indicated the presence of what
can only be assumed to be artificially
created components great gears
resembling Clockwork structures and even
rudimentary circuitry were present
throughout the creature's body the
function or origin of these gears has
yet to be determined especially as there
is no evident way that their movement
corresponds to the autonomy and movement
of the serpent itself the far more
striking Discovery however came when the
SCP Foundation discovered a way to
communicate with the two beasts Ultra
lowf frequency waves capable of
traveling vast dist instances even light
years were discovered to be emitted from
the two serpent heads at intermittent
periods the foundation had to developed
some of the largest antenna ever created
to pick up these frequencies and
interpret the data coming through them
what they found were two twins locked in
a fierce debate about the fate of
humanity and the universe itself it was
only then that the motivations of these
two serpents started to make sense in
2010 almost as soon as the foundation
was was able to tap into the frequency
they were contacted directly by a CP
468-1 fion I know that you can hear me I
will not apologize for my actions I know
that I am the reason that millions of
your kind face their demise I know your
pain and I feel it too but I shall never
apologize for it I simply ask you to
listen to myself and to my word cannot
be translated you are curious you can be
patient exercise that and you may one
day understand and listen the foundation
did efforts to contain or destroy the
two serpents were put on the back burner
instead Foundation agents prioritize
spreading disinformation across South
America and Beyond about the source of
these earthquakes the two serpents are
far too large and far too powerful to
overcome or contain instead the
foundation prioritized the use of
amnestic drugs disinformation and the
creation of Fringe conspiracy groups to
discredit any claims of the serpent
respective existences meanwhile some of
the most senior leadership figures in
the foundation were and still are locked
in a fierce debate as to what to do with
the twin serpents by listening to the
communication between the two scps the
foundation discovered that SCP
45682 is intent on wiping out the entire
human race the only thing that has
prevented it from being able to do so
thus far has been the existence of the
other serpent every time that SCP
45682 begins to mount an attack on
Humanity its land bearing twin triggers
enormous earthquakes to disrupt its
progress but why would the sea serpent
want to destroy the human race as
Foundation generals gathered in the deep
sea operations base SCP 4 5
68-20 you poison the oceans taint the
rivers blacken the skies you do not need
angels of death to destroy your world
but there is something else I see it in
the Bott bottom of your eyes something
Unforgettable unconceivable ideas
cloaked in Madness and impossible colors
do you think I will let you drag the
rest of the world down with
yourselves do you think I will leave
this world my world to Die In Flames it
sees your world and it comes in
fives since this revelation the
foundation has poured countless hours
and resources into trying to identify a
cosmic threat for well over a decade
many of the smartest scientists the
world has to offer have looked to the
night sky scanning for this impossible
color this shroud of Madness but to no
avail some within the foundation believe
the serpent is lying trying to make up
an excuse to justify its genocide but
information from SCP
468-1 seems to confirm everyone's worst
spars your minds burn bright fasion all
of humanity shines from this rock like a
candle in a dark room it sees you an
idea exists only because something
thought of it have you ever considered
how such terrible Concepts could have
been given form what kind of atrocious
mind could even think about it humans
cannot conceive the colorless green what
if you are playing into this creature's
hands there appears to be an underlying
implication that ideas are the source of
power somehow this colorless green this
unimaginable Cosmic threat seems to be a
monstrous idea incarnate but whose idea
Humanities there is a deep lore that the
two serpents discuss with one another
one that makes little sense even to this
day to the foundation they talk of gods
and goddesses deities of Flesh of Steel
and gears and of the fives quite what
these creatures are if they are even
creatures at all is a mystery to the
foundation researchers have not
discovered a way of communicating back
with the two serpents directly attempts
to mimic their language or transmit
signals asking questions to them have
largely been ignored instead they
address humanity and the foundation as a
whole seeming to take the view of the
human race as being a collective hive
mind one that they are evidently able to
tap into the pair seem uninterested in
informing us as to exactly what this
threat is or explaining who the gods and
goddesses are perhaps they assume we
know these things already or more likely
they believe that our Consciousness is
not yet capable of perceiving the scale
and depth of the concepts that they are
debating what is clear however is their
shared understanding that if Humanity
were to be eliminated the candle was to
be blown out this Cosmic threat would
pass by the pair have names Tren is the
land serpent while remaining dormant
much of the time in an enormous Cave
System beneath the Andes Mountains this
serpent seems Keen to help the
foundation in some way Kai the sea
serpent is intent on sacrificing the
human race for a greater good one far
beyond our understanding speaking to the
foundation in the Andes Mountains trenen
gave a short speech that serve both as
encouragement and a terrible warning of
the darkness to come it is something I
like about you fion about Mankind while
it is easy to just take the simplest
path to just give up there will always
be some among you who refuse this path
who do the right thing maybe not all of
you are this strong but I can see it in
your methods those so-called containment
procedures there will always be someone
who stands up against the dark even if
it takes a thousand million years to
emerge Victorious maybe you can stop
thefe after all ideas can be killed with
better ideas even if it takes a thousand
million years the fist collides with
Humphrey's face crumpling him to the
ground like a cheap greasy Burger King
rapper he fig feels the lingering sting
of the punch on his skin and in the
marrow of his cheekbone the man who
punched him a tall muscular handsome man
will refer to as Chad stands above him
with his fist still clenched according
to Chad Humphrey Bingham the pale doughy
43-year-old lying on the ground with a
bruise forming on his cheek had been
inappropriately hitting on his
girlfriend she told him to deal with the
situation and he had with one definitive
bar to leave his beloved alone Chad
turns and walks away leaving Humphrey on
the ground his face and pride equally
bruised a few hours later Humphrey is
sitting alone in a train car rattling
down the tracks in the direction of his
depressing bachelor's apartment he's
shaking with rage people they're
disgusting creatures really he thinks to
himself worthless animals that are
capable of nothing but cruelty and
exclusion they always let him down
always hurt him always made fun of him
every day getting up to face loneliness
and isolation felt like being attacked
by a pack of wild dogs one thought Rings
loud and clear in his mind it'd be best
if someone had the guts to just wipe out
the human race no even more than that
annihilate all life in existence wipe
clean the slate and salt the Earth so
that somebody or something more worthy
could grow that was the Fate at everyone
else deserve for making his 43 years on
this Earth so miserable but beneath all
that there is another thought that's
making him smile he's got a plan a plan
that nobody else knows about a plan to
make everyone pay for every time they've
crossed Humphrey Bingham Humphrey you
see has an interesting job he works at
an infectious disease laboratory fans of
apocalyptic fiction are probably putting
together the picture already maybe he's
going to leak an infectious pathogen or
even worse combine and engineer multiple
pathogens together in order to make the
super virus capable of bringing Humanity
to its knees but that's where you would
be wrong Humphrey does have a vial in
his coat containing traces of the
Bubonic plague but his intentions with
it are actually far weirder soon enough
he arrives home and secretes himself
away in his Bleak little apartment it is
a drab and gray place except of course
for his weapons bizarre and impossible
blades iridescent like oil slicks in a
crazed rainbow of variety Blades of all
shapes and sizes from daggers to switch
blades to axes that technically weren't
legal to own you see Humphrey Bingham is
what we know as a mul ninja a slang term
for someone who buys cheap and
impractical decorative weapons for
display around their home but the pride
of his collection has to be the
apocalyptic death metal sword as he's
dubed it it sits on a stand in the
middle of all the others bright purple
and covered in so many sharp edges it's
almost impossible to hold he has been
refining and perfecting it for years in
some places the edges are a single atom
thin giving them inconceivable cutting
power and when we say that he has been
perfecting it we don't just mean
sharpening and polishing littered around
the room room are different volumes on
the occult particularly those concerned
with enchanting objects he's been
conducting spells and rituals grinding
up desert locust shells and illegally
purchased human bones and saying
incantations he's drawn all the proper
pentagrams and tonight he's obtained the
decisive ingredient he needs to make his
plans a reality the Bubonic plague
sample saying the complex
incomprehensible words of a spell he'
memorized Humphrey B produces the vial
and carefully pours it across the
apocalyptic death metal sword it glows
and tingles radiating with pure power
and Humphrey finds himself giggling with
uncontrollable Glee he imagines scenes
from The Book of Revelation his favorite
part of the New Testament where Satan
Rises and the war between him and God
destroys and later remakes the Earth he
imagines his mighty sword as an agent of
almost Heavenly power dealing brutal
judgment on the evil and the weak back
in reality Humphrey's insane dream might
just be coming true but in an even
grander manner than he'd imagined the
apocalyptic death metal sword floats off
of its stand but it isn't alone three
other smaller swords from his collection
also rise up the weapons that had been
practiced for all of his experiments it
seems they'd been a success a terrible
rousing success but Umphrey's dreams
quickly turn into a nightmare as the
enchanted swords begin to fight each
other but it isn't some free-for-all
Battle Royale all the smaller swords are
teaming up against the apocalyptic death
metal sword and the smaller swords are
losing as the wildly flailing death
sword slashes them into tiny fragments
of metal it is an act of rampant stide
and Humphrey can only stare on in horror
though the Rampage is nowhere near over
when the lesser of the swords are no
more the apocalyptic death metal sword
flails insanely as though battling
invisible monsters already it's far
beyond Humphrey bingham's control but
there is a method to this madness a
method that Humphrey himself is
literally unable to see the apocalyptic
death metal sword is so dedicated to the
Grand Mission of destroying life that
even bacteria cannot Escape its
stainless steel wrath on a microscopic
level every swing cleanly Cuts one of
the microscopic life forms in half this
terrifying weapon truly does not plan on
letting any of its potential victims
Escape up to and including the
unfortunate Humphrey Bingham himself
before he's even had time to scream and
run the sword turns on him it flies in
his Direction at Mock four speed and
unleashes an impossible flurry of
slashes by the time it's done there's
literally nothing left not even blood
just an empty room full of broken swords
where the creator of this apocalyptic
weapon has been cleaved into Oblivion on
the atomic level but the sword is not
done it slashes through the door and
heads out into the wider World ready to
pursue its Deadly Mission it isn't long
until researchers at a local Foundation
containment site catch wind of something
strange going on in the city they
intercept some frantic police chatter
about officers fighting off a sword no
not a person holding a sword just a
sword rather than just assume it's some
kind of strange police incident like the
time those two on duty cops avoided
investigating a robbery to get a Snorlax
on Pokémon go the site director quickly
dispatches a heavily armed mobile task
force on the scene it is a complete
bloodbath officers and civilians lay
dead in the streets as the sword
continues to fly around at impossible
speed what had initially been several
squad cars worth of responding officers
had been reduced to a mere handful of
scared stragglers what they've seen
today would completely rewrite their
understanding of reality even if it was
wasn't actively murdering their
co-workers and trying to murder them too
in the brief periods where the
apocalyptic death metal sword isn't
cutting down cops and civilians it is
continuing to flail madly through the
air slicing more insects and microscopic
beings seemingly nothing can stop its
Rampage and that's when the mobile task
force helicopter arrives along with two
ground units in armored tactical
vehicles for support it's the kind of
precautions you can expect when the SCP
Foundation isn't entire enely sure what
they're up against and little do they
know they're going to need all of them
if they want any hope of surviving and
defeating the apocalyptic death metal
sword but they're going to lose a lot of
good men before then MTF Troopers start
repelling down from the helicopter
wielding Advanced tactical assault
rifles they're able to lock onto the
Diabolical Maul Ninja Blade and open
fire hitting it with a hail of
armor-piercing bullets but those bullets
resoundingly fail to pierce whatever
anomalous armor maintains the
apocalyptic death metal sword's
structural Integrity the bullets
ricochet off making sounds like popcorn
kernels rattling around in a tin can the
blades counter offensive would be a lot
more effective it locks on to the most
dangerous Target first perhaps out of
pure bad luck on the part of the MTF
squads the helicopter pilot the sword
flies for him faster than he could
possibly move his vehicle out of its
path it skewers the cockpit traveling
straight through his chest and out the
other side of the helicopter the vehicle
consequently spins out and explodes
torpedoing its burning carus down onto
the street below things are starting to
get interesting as the other operatives
pile out of the ground vehicles and
start firing on the flash of deadly
purple steel the massacre continues the
sword fing through Foundation tactical
armor like Playdoh their bullets can't
harm the device or even really slow it
down a frightening thought passes
through the mind of one of the
operatives if this thing is left
unchecked for long enough it could
blossom into an XK Class end of the
world scenario there is no follow-up
thought though because the sword passed
through his mind moments afterwards
leaving him cold and dead on the ground
as the battle rages on Victory clearly
on the side of the apocalyptic death
metal sword the egg heads back at the
nearest Foundation containment site are
screaming to think up of a contingency
plan an entity wielding a weapon is is
easily enough to kill or at least
disable but a weapon without an entity
that still keeps on attacking feels
almost impossible they're desperately
trying to collect information about the
anomalous item from the field but
anytime one of the operatives is able to
radio back they're killed by the sword
before they can impart any useful
information all that's left to try is
the nuclear option thankfully not
literally when conventional teams fail
they have certain experimental mobile
task forces namely mobile task force
Omega 7 Pandora's Box and one particular
member of that team who has expertise in
that area SCP
076-2
AEL The Immortal Warrior years before
the incident of mass killing that would
cause the team to be disbanded while the
apocalyptic death metal sword did its
thing the rest of the team was being
dispatched to fetch AEL out of Cold
Storage the second that this terrifying
tattooed Warrior is told that he'll be
up against another blade he's chomping
at the bit he's dragged into a
high-speed helicopter and taken to the
scene as quickly as possible fitted with
an earpiece so he can tell exactly what
he learns about the apocalyptic death
metal sword over to Mission command Abel
agreed on the condition that he could go
all out on his enemy for once his
handlers didn't mind granting him that
permission after all nobody was even
really sure if it was possible to hurt
an enemy like this about an hour into
the ramp rage Abel arrives touching down
on the concrete so hard that it buckles
beneath his feet he sees the sword
floating there hideous and garish even
by his standards is his opponent
invisible it doesn't matter he'll slay
them all the same he produces two of his
obsidian swords and charges in as the
sword seems to notice his presence and
flies towards him at incredible speeds
it takes his truly superlative reflexes
along with his considerable strength to
Parry the weapon at the decisive minute
before it can pierce his wretched heart
it's so much faster than he expected
he's almost impressed the blade does not
wait it circles and Strikes him again as
he deflects and Strikes at it with his
own swords and then something impossible
happens his swords break this hideous
purple blade has sliced clean through
them causing them to fall onto the floor
in multiple black pieces this is
impossible how could this blade have
bested his own over his earpiece his
handlers ask him for information on the
blade anything they can use AEL says
that the weapon doesn't make sense it
has the quality of mere steel but it was
somehow unbreakable that is all the
handlers need to hear they begin
immediately putting their contingency
measures into place they just need able
to buy them a little more time will he
be able to give the apocalyptic death
metal sword a good enough fight the
battle is strange ly one of the toughest
he's ever faced his opponent feels no
pain no fear it doesn't even think or
feel it attacks and kills on pure
Instinct every time he pulls out a new
weapon an axe a sword a Warhammer a
chainsaw it's already upon Him slashing
away with unimaginable speed and
ferocity it matches his own as every
Parry is met with a perfect counter
Parry he's now getting to grips with the
fact that his opponent opponent isn't
holding a weapon his opponent is a
weapon but he still refuses to let this
be an easy fight he summons a huge
obsidian broadsword from the space
between spaces and lunges in clashing
blades with the edges of the apocalyptic
death metal sword he feels its strength
and its speed its desire to deal death
to everything it was pure it was
glorious when the foundation
reinforcements arrive Abel is dead don't
worry he'll get back
with the apocalyptic death metal sword
sticking out of his chest after finding
out that the sword is made of steel the
foundation operatives were able to
devise a powerful electromagnet one
capable of getting this unruly weapon of
mass destruction under some semblance of
control with the sword enables body
retrieved this supernatural weapon now
labeled SCP
3749 is placed inside a vacuum chamber
completely sterilized in that scenario
the weapon simply shook around on the
floor a shadow of its terrifying former
self without even bacteria to destroy it
can only turn on itself and lay there in
the dark another dangerous anomaly
secured contained and soon to be
protected a textbook case for the
foundation's central Mission these days
SCP 3749 sits inside a fitted
hermetically sealed chamber full of
kinetic gel designed to suppress its
constant urge to slash and stab any and
all line
if ever that seal is broken we just hope
you're nearby or in the very brief
period you'll still be alive you may
learn firsthand what it feels like to be
sushi in that regard the miserable
Legacy of Humphrey Bingham is unlike the
man himself alive and well the year was
2015 Lewis Joseph and Sydney were like a
lot of kids their age which is to say 11
years old they secretly stay up past
their bedtime watching scary videos on
the internet when their moms and dads
think they're sleeping they go to school
every day and daydream about all the fun
things they're going to do when that
school bell finally rings at the end of
the day and of course they play a lot
and we mean a lot of Minecraft whenever
they're not at school hanging out at the
local park and filming goofy Tik Tok
videos or watching those AFF
forementioned scary videos on the
internet there's a good chance that
they'll be online together logging a few
extra hours building bases digging big
holes or playing survival mode and
seeing how long they can last against
the onslaught of mobs but there's one
particular Pursuit they have while
playing Minecraft together that takes up
the majority of their playtime one
chotic Quest that drives them forward
despite all the naysayers and doubters
tracking down and finding the legendary
Minecraft creepy pasta entity Herobrine
for those who weren't around on the
internet back then creepy pastas like
herob Bren were all the rage like any
video game the new frontier of Minecraft
with all of its procedurally generated
Landscapes felt like it held new
Mysteries and Mysteries are equal parts
exciting and frightening after all who
really knows what's going on behind a
closed door Herobrine was a Minecraft
specific little urban legend stories
told of a default Minecraft skin with
early white eyes manifesting in the game
even in solo matches and terrorizing
players one internet sleuth who looked
into the mystery of Herobrine claimed it
to be the haunted soul of the Dead
Brother of Minecraft's Creator Marcus
Pon also known as notch in the years
since the legend first started Notch
himself has come forward and disavowed
the claim saying that in fact he didn't
even have a brother and never had so the
rumors were completely baseless but as
we here at the SCP Foundation no the
truth has never gotten in the way of a
good story so Lewis Joseph and Sydney
were happy to remain Believers as long
as they could keep having fun chasing
alleged digital ghosts how could any of
these boys know that in the midst of
their fun they'd run into a real monster
amidst Minecraft's blocky Vistas it was
a school night like any other when they
made that first fateful Expedition it
was 7:15 p.m. and the boys were all in
their shared server Lewis had chicken
tenders Joseph had chicken nuggets and
Sydney who'd eaten his dinner earlier
than the others was snacking on a pack
of Skittles they' all outfitted their
characters with full diamond armor with
diamond swords to match because Joseph
had somehow convinced the others that
diamonds were ghost proof he read it on
the internet he claimed together the
three boys had made themselves an
impressive Minecraft castle to be the
base of their Herobrine hunting
operations a safe haven surrounded by
high stone walls and mob repelling
torches to keep them safe if ever they
got a little too spooked while playing
though playing was perhaps too mild the
word for it in the minds of these three
boys they were doing extremely important
investigative work after all if they
managed to actually find Herobrine
themselves they would be creepy pasta
Legends and wouldn't that be worth all
the hours upon hours of rigorous Mining
and crafting they'd been methodical in
their search scoping out different
corners of the map and canvasing them
together surging high and low and then
marking said area off their checklist it
was a level of consideration and thought
that their parents and teachers had long
wished the boys would put into their
home or schoolwork but alas seeing as
none of the homework was find Herobrine
they really weren't that interested
today they were searching an area deep
in the misty forests in the dead of
night they fought off a few spiders and
sword wielding skeletons thankfully no
creepers oh man and and kept foraging on
into the darkness it's so creepy out
here L said over his headset why do we
have to come out here at night it it's
way more dangerous with all the mobs but
night is like the perfect time for
ghosts Sydney retorted you think a ghost
is going to start hanging around in the
middle of the day no way it's got to be
a night man and Lewis simply could not
argue with such incredibly Sound Logic
they forged on doing their typical
methodical search for any phenomenon
that one might generously be able to
describe as Supernatural so you can only
imagine the excitement coursing through
them when Joseph discovered a strange
dark cave that looked as though it had
no business being there while each held
their own private reservations they all
knew what they needed to do go inside
and investigate as they entered the cave
a few strange realizations occurred to
them such as the fact that there were
seemingly no mobs down here the cave in
the dead of night surely there should be
some enemies right plus the typical
lighting implements like torches and
lanterns didn't seem to offer the same
kind of Illumination that they normally
would it was almost like the darkness
was more oppressive here more tangible
there was undeniably something Eerie
about the whole setup that much couldn't
be denied you guys see anything LS asked
no Joseph said sounding oddly cautious
as though he sensed something strange
was on the horizon something that
perhaps these boys shouldn't see yeah I
haven't seen anything either Sydney
chimed in maybe we should Joseph
screamed and the two others turned their
Minecraft Avatars to look at him
Joseph's character had bumped into
something some stranger in the cave an
NPC design that looked oddly realistic
for something inhabiting the
purposefully lowii blocky world of
Minecraft it seemed to have a dark furry
body with a caned skull-like face
bearing a pair of milky white eyes that
seemed to stare off into nothingness was
this another mob maybe something added
in the latest patch if so why wasn't it
attacking what is that thing leis asked
over his headset I don't know Joseph
replied it's so creepy though suddenly a
message appeared on the screen as though
it had been typed and sent by another
player a player with the username Mal o
the message read hey that isn't very
nice you shouldn't judge on appearances
kid that certainly gave them pause so
many things about this didn't make sense
at all the Hallmarks of an NPC but
apparently it understood their voices
and could send messages it clearly
wasn't actually another player in a
conventional sense but it didn't attack
like your typical mob none of the boys
could really make sense of what they
were dealing with here are you a hacker
Sydney asked no Mal o typed back I'm
just lonely and a long way from home
it's nice to have your company down here
though I don't get visitors often have
you heard of Herobrine Louis asked mow
typed back is he a friend of yours you
should introduce him to me I love making
new friends the three boys were in some
regards rather mature and polite for
their ages and so remained civil with
this bizarre mysterious figure it was
curious and inquisitive asking them
questions about their school lives and
their friends it did seem earnestly
happy for their company so it didn't
give any of them the sense that it was a
threat as night Drew on in the boy
respective parents told them it was time
to log off and get some sh ey mow
finally typed I've really enjoyed
hanging out with you kids come back and
visit me again tomorrow if you don't
I'll come visit you instead none of the
kids picked up on the probably rather
obvious stranger danger Vibes of this
message and instead they went to bed
excited and curious the next day they
met up on the playground for a kind of
State of the Union on the strange
phenomenon they had encountered the
night before do you think it has
anything to do with Herobrine Louis
asked forget Herobrine Sydney replied
eliciting gasp from the two others all
the other people have Herobrine we have
something better something only we've
discovered we've got Malo later that
night Joseph who was probably the most
studious of the group tried to do a
little background research on Mal o
everything seemed to turn up dead ends
aside from one slightly Shady looking
app called Mal o version
1.0.0 its description read never settle
for those awkward feelings of being
alone ever again Malo is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but just after a few hours of Malo you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new cze that is quickly becoming the
next social substitute remember the more
you participate the more Mal o will
engage you your experience is completely
up to you absolutely no ads enjoy weird
so unless the thing they encountered on
Minecraft was some kind of weird viral
marketing campaign for the app it was
probably just a coincidence maybe it was
a popular character from Japan or
something by the way for the next
several days the boys honored their
promise they'd visit Mal o in the cave
every night and chat trying to tactfully
get more information out of it though
the best they could get on the entity's
origin was the cryptic statement I'm not
usually here but everyone wants a
vacation once in a while don't they we
can't just spend our whole life on a
phone they'd become so acclimated to Mal
o over the days that they forgot what
the entity had said to them the very
first day they met come back and visit
me again tomorrow if you don't I'll come
visit you instead but on the day that
they didn't come and visit Mal o because
Miss Grayson had sent a particularly
challenging piece of English homework
they received a frightening reminder
that very night they all started
receiving strange texts on their phones
as you can probably expect they were all
photographs each and everyone depicting
some regular haunt that the boys all
like to frequent with one addition Mal
O's grinning skull face hiding somewhere
in the image like some kind of demented
parody of where's Waldo the strangeness
of this new development left all the
boys shaken and they hopped back onto
Minecraft as quickly as possible to go
find and talk to Malo in its cave
however this time the cave was empty and
Malo was nowhere to be seen
but the Tex still didn't stop it'd come
in so frequently with malow getting
closer to home literally in each one the
boys thought about telling their parents
but would their parents believe them
they probably lump Mal Owen with the
same Tall Tales of childhood imagination
as Herobrine and write it off as boor
kids playing a prank even though in this
case it was anything but more photos
arrived in these ones Mal o was right
outside each of the children's homes
lurking watching in some of the photos
they could see themselves in the windows
going about their evening business
having no idea of the creature lurking
just outside none of the boys felt like
playing Minecraft that night it wasn't
fun anymore instead they shut themselves
up in their rooms closed and locked
their windows and pulled down the blinds
after checking under the beds with
flashlights of course but still more
photos came in all depicting Mal o
getting closer and closer and closer
right about the time they were wondering
whether the scratching on the outside of
their bedroom door was real or just a
figment of their imagination another
dark irony had occurred to them all this
time trying to find something
Supernatural and in the very end
something Supernatural had instead found
them want an anomaly of your own check
out SCP swag.com for highquality SCP
merch stop Bri up folks we've got all
kinds of refreshing and tasty treats
here for you today popcorn peanuts
cotton candy and even fried dough Yer
here at SCP explained we're offering the
top-of-the-line anomalous delectable
food stuffs for all your circus themed
Funtime occasions and that's because
today yes today on this YouTube platform
our Infamous acronym doesn't stand for
secure contain protect it stands for
sweet confectionary products and let me
tell you dear viewer the SCP we're
looking at today just might be the most
decadent durable and dangerous dessert
that's ever desired to be devoured we're
talking about SCP
377 or as they are better known the
sugar Golems these little fellas are
safe class and are so totally harmless
so long as you take the proper
precautions what's the matter don't you
believe me don't you think it's nice of
us to cover a safe SCP now and again and
hey now why all this dull talk about
rules and regulations in the first place
you don't go out to the carnival to not
take wild and exciting r risks every
spinny twirly and whirly ride on the
fairgrounds comes with a statistically
higher chance of a tragic mishap
befalling you and any other Thrill
Seekers around you but we all take that
chance anyway for the extraordinary Rush
of the experience and such is the wacky
and wonderful ways of our adorable and
questionably edible Chums the sugar
Golems don't you just love them folks
ain't they a sight for sore eyes and a
pay for sweet teeth well we're only just
getting stuck Ed The Best Is Yet To Come
ladies and non ladies so pull up a chair
and be sure to watch what we've got in
store you can make like a piece of old
candy and stick around now that's a knce
slapper ain't
it sit back relax and make sure to enjoy
the show you should also subscribe to
SCP explain if you'd like to continue to
be entertained hey that rhymed what do
you know I'm a boat and I didn't even
know it out roll while SCP 377 refers to
the anomalous substance contained in
sight 81 the semi-humanoid instances
which are nicknamed sugar Golems are
themselves an animate and independent
byproduct that naturally spawns from SCP
377 when it is allowed to exist outside
of containment procedures the most
important of these containment
procedures being that SCP 3077 must
remain at a constant temperature of well
below its freezing point and only be
stored in containers full to capacity
less its aformentioned byproducts
attempt to breach container
the total volume of SCP 3077 within the
cryogenic containment unit equals almost
2200 L and it is believed to be the only
known quantity of the anomalous
substance in existence for the sake of
clarity in distinguishing between SCP
3077 and its byproducts will be
referring to the main object contained
by the foundation as SCP 3077 while the
gooey little guys who we know to
spontaneously split off from the source
of SCP 377 will be regarded as SCP
30771 as mentioned before SCP 30771
instances have been affectionately
dubbed the sugar Golems every instance
of SCP 30771 resembles an approximately
1 M tall gaunt humanoid composed of a
pure sugar derived substance commonly
known as prle and that's meiosis for all
y'all ye cow boys over there in the US R
if you've ever played the classic board
game Candyland you'll have some idea of
what an individual instance of SCP 3077
looks like from the Beloved and often
remembered character of Gloppy who lives
in the Molasses swamp section of the
board and is also fittingly made out of
molasses himself yes indeed Gloppy is
truly a delight for a weary Candyland
player to meet what did you say are you
folks too young to know about Candyland
well that factoid certainly makes this
narrat or feel pretty old then again I
am taking on the mannerisms and attire
of an oldfashioned Carnival Barker so I
suppose a bit of Novel Antiquity comes
with the
territory regardless the Golems are each
composed of roughly 7 lers of sweet syy
goodness and very much like everyone's
favorite character Gloppy they all lack
toine lower bodies and can all emote
through crude yet oddly endearing
vocalizations in the place of
intelligible speech while their facial
features are simplistic and misshapen
the Contours of concave eyes and gaping
mouth are usually present the exact
number of these eyes and mouths is
subject to very ation much like the
color of the board spaces in a wonderful
wholesome family game of Candyland while
H SC SCP 30771 instance is around the
same size the body proportions and
overall shape of each instance are
rather fluid pun fully intended some
possess oversized arms or bulbous heads
While others might be conjoined to an
adjacent sugar golum as if to show that
the two are inseparable as a pair of
best buddies or as some others might put
it a couple of
BFFs best friends for fancy frolicking
they really are quite friendly looking
aren't they and aren't they they sure
are for the only thing that these sugary
sweet SCP instances want is to be in the
company of human beings just like you
yes you who else would I be talking to
it's a hard life for this warn down
Connie let me tell you these little
sugar Golems love what they do and do
what they love but that doesn't mean
that it's time for Fun and Games even
though SCP 37 77-1 instances want to
hang around human beings they don't tend
to stop at hey and hello or whatever
those appropriate greetings sound like
when they are being gurgled by a
dimunitive molten sugar monster things
can get out of hand real fast just like
an orange cream popsicle melting in the
sun of a late summer's day now listen up
it's important that you pay attention to
what I say next I'm about to book learn
you about what to do if an instance of
SCP 30771 enters your personal space the
results of prolonged contact with with
this SCP can end badly if you're not
careful I'm not going to sugarcoat any
of the chewy details of your Grizzly
fate and I promise that it won't be a
cakewalk so don't be a nerd and listen
up yes that's right I called you a nerd
you know like nerds the candy how do you
folks seriously not know nerds they were
classic Halloween candy from the Wonka
company and they were very popular back
in the day oh what's that you say how
long ago was it back in the day for me
that's a bit of a root question wouldn't
you say oh won't you go ahead and off
with the Wise Guy questions what are you
a pack of
Smarties I said Smarties get it just
like that ah never mind let's just move
on to the explanation of how to survive
a close encounter with this SCP that was
the main reason you came all this way to
this here educational and entertaining
video presentation after all to pick up
where I left off instances of SCP 3771
have a tendency to seek out nearby human
life the reason for doing so is
surprisingly simple and alarmingly well
alarming these sticky sacin simulakra
are sely set on slithering into people's
mouths for the purposes of gaining total
control of their bodies Yes you heard
that right believe it or not the same
anomalous propery which animates the
sugar Golem's treal bodies is apparently
capable of overriding the human nervous
system from the inside and that's no
joke folks while these tasty treats
might sound sweet to eat you'll be a
puppet of meat from from your head to
your feet if you don't complete the
tasks I entreat if an instance of SCP
30771 attempts to enter your mouth you
must remember first and foremost to keep
your trap shut blocking it with a mask
or similar article of clothing if need
be next you must use your limbs and all
available implements to batter the
attacking Golem away while you do your
best to keep a distance of at least Arms
Reach between yourself and the instance
it should come as a relief to our
rational people that SCP 30771 instances
are severely limited in their physical
capabilities and an adult human of
average fitness can easily hold one off
if they know what to expect the tricky
part comes from the amorphous properties
of the instance's viscous prle bodies as
well as their anomalous ability to
regenerate from any physical trauma the
only way to permanently destroy an
instance of SCP
30771 is to expose it to temperatures
above its melting point which for use
sticklers out there is approximately
176° C the most effective weapons
against their CP 377 D1 instances
include firebombs flamethrowers and your
run-of-the-mill convection ovens if it
is at all possible to contain the
instance within a sealed vessel such as
a large Tupperware or wooden barrel then
you ought to do whatever you can to
prevent the candy creeps from running a
mck while ordinary below zero
temperatures are unable to destroy the
anomalous treal of of SCP 3077 instances
of SCP
30771 can effectively be slowed down or
stopped completely if you put them on
Ice whether it's the hot foot or the
cold shoulder some form of extreme
temperature should always be weaponize
when defending oneself from an SCP 30771
instance any attempt to crush or smash
an SCP 30771 instance will only result
in the bad bon bon breaking apart and
reforming into several more belligerent
bikes size blighters a human Under Siege
by the sugar Golems might find
themselves quickly outnumbered if they
foolishly attempt to use a melee weapon
against the anomalies basically it's
like a more delicious version of the
popular arcade video game asteroids no
eh I guess that reference was from
before even my time at any rate
instances of SCP 30771 are difficult to
destroy without access to heat or
freezing the tendency of the Molasses
menaces to increase in number is made
even than worse because of the fact that
any amount of SCP 3077 outside of
containment can generate a nearly
infinite number of SCP
30771 while even an army of SCP 30771
instances is far weaker than an
equivalent pack of hunting animals the
ability to continuously multiply and
Physiology that doesn't experience the
consequences of fatigue means that given
enough time these sugar Golems can
Outlast any amount of human resistance
until they roll over their preferred
prey like a slow insurmountable syrupy
tsunami of surrender seriously scary
stuff some would say but what happens
next is the real kicker folks mind this
balo's somber Spiel if an instance of
SCP 30771 manages to Against All Odds
clamber its way into a human chatter box
and hijack the poor Sap's nervous system
the victim is immediately classified as
SCP
377-2 SCP 377-2 instances are easily
distinguished from unaffected humans on
site alone dark tendrils of SCP 3077 can
be seen visibly moving beneath the skin
and often emerge from the mouth to
crisscross the instance's face like
makeup the world's most disturbing
circus clown that's not all after that
tragic trly transformation takes place
the movements exhibited by the instance
of SCP
377-2 will become crooked and Jerky like
a marionette puppeteered by a frustrated
chimpanzee during this time the instant
remains fully conscious retaining
whatever cognitive faculties it has
possessed previous to its classification
but it is unable to attempt speech or
exert autonomy over its own actions this
fun fact was discovered by studying the
EEG recordings of several SCP 377-2
instances and is brought to you by the
United Guild of the existentially
terrified if an instance of SCP 377-2
happens to wander its way into the
vicinity of any humans that haven't
succumbed to the process of consuming
SCP
30771 it will proceed to put on a juny
performance for its new found audience
this peculiar display involves clumsy
efforts at dance choreography and the
throaty singing of unsettling Eternal
Melodies that would make your annoying
cousins road trip songs sound like
they're in tune these awkward
performances continue until the audience
departs from the view of SCP 377-2
instance or the instance expires this
confirms that the point of the gesture
is to entertain as without an audience
the SCP 377-2 instance is not compelled
to make any noises of its own accord and
in general doesn't do anything other
than move around aimlessly in the event
that any number of SC SCP 30771
instances escapes from containment and
causes the creation of SCP
377-2 members of the mobile task force
are instructed to never stray from the
line of sight of a currently performing
SCP 377-2 instance and to approach it
steadily before restraining the instance
while causing minimal harm to the body
SCP 377-2 instances can be useful for
running further tests on the anomalous
properties of SCP 3077 and there are
simple procedures that allow an instance
to be kept alive indefinitely in
containment any damage sustained during
capture can severely hamper the
efficiency of these life sustaining
procedures the worst case scenario is
that an SCP 377-2 instance expires
before being securely contained as this
will cause the SCP 30771 instance to
emerge from its host and resume its
Relentless attack on all nearby humans
it is far easier to Simply deal with SCP
377-2 instances accordingly and this is
because SCP
377-2 only ever attempts to continue the
performance and possesses neither the
intention nor the capacity for
retaliation if it is deemed necessary
for the effectiveness of a capture
effort it can be permissible for the
mobile task force to allow instances of
SCP 30771 outside of containing to find
purchase within SCP
377-2 to increase the ease of
containment and lessen the risk of
foundation Personnel being affected the
performances of SCP 377-2 instances are
rarely physically intensive enough to
make capture too difficult but it can be
said that the Whimsical antics of these
affected humans are anything but
predictable
during some rare and special
performances and if the SCP 30771
instance in control of SCP 377-2
instance is feeling especially daring it
may try to show off an array of woefully
inadequate acrobatic skills front flips
that are more like belly flops back
flips that could be mistaken for pret
Falls and the sort of typ Roo P trap
acts that are better left to the
imagination in lie of Prior incidents
the foundation strongly advises that if
for any any reason an instance of SCP
377-2 must exist in containment it must
always be prevented from being at an
altitude of more than 6 ft from the
surface of the floor especially if any
humans it would perceive as an audience
are located directly beneath where its
performance would take place regarding
the creation of further instances of SCP
377-2 requests from any level of
foundation Personnel at site 81 or
elsewhere must be granted permission to
proceed by SCP 3077 head researcher
because of the horrific implications of
what happens to the still aware human
mind while the body is affected by SCP
30771 this process is only to be
approved for use on d-class Personnel
that's right and even then in the event
that all the rigoll of the paperwork
goes through it is not acceptable to
create an instance of SCP
377-2 merely for the purpose of
providing live entertainment to fellow
researchers
after all not a single one of us should
be quick to forget the grotesque and
highly regrettable spectacle that was Dr
deetz's deplorable d-class dancers every
researcher involved with that ethical
nightmare was reprimanded severely and
the colorful novelty costumes and
jangling bells that all former d-class
Personnel were made to wear after being
reclassified to SCP
377-2 have been permanently confiscated
let the cotton candy machine and peanut
dispenser located just outside the
containment unit of SC p377 serve as a
Stern reminder that there's a time and
place for Monkey Shines and Tom Foolery
and sometimes yes even now and then a
highly secure Foundation facility is
neither the right place nor the right
time in case you haven't picked up on it
there are very few practical
applications of SCP 3077 due to the fact
that its status as a food dish is
negated by the consequences of
consumption the main reason for test to
be administered on SCP 377-2 instant es
is to discover if there is a safe method
of extracting an SCP 30771 instance from
the body of its host without causing the
expiration of the original human
unfortunately due to a persistent lack
of success the experiments have been
discontinued indefinitely but that just
won't do how else are we supposed to
know if these things actually taste as
good as they look I won't rest until
everyone is able to harmlessly ingest a
sugar Golem of their very own I might be
old passion but to me the safe object
class isn't just a designation it's an
invitation I ought to be completely okay
doing whatever I like around a safed
object because it's safe that word
should actually mean something ding ding
darn it and I don't mean that in the
sense that the SCP Foundation uses it
meaning an anomaly that doesn't present
an active threat to containment efforts
and more importantly there aren't that
many anomalies that are also delicious
candy and I want to eat this one sorry
sorry sorry I lost my coolit there I
just have a sweet tooth and my brain is
constantly drifting back to my nostalgic
childhood memories of playing Candyland
with my family that was before they all
decided that they wanted nothing to do
with me because I became so obsessed
with dressing up like a carnival bker
that I drove away everyone who's ever
cared about me other than that my job
here at the foundation explaining
confectionary SC scps is the only thing
I have left in my sad sad life some days
I feel less like Gloppy and more like a
real lord licorice in Hard Times Like
These a fellow could really use some
entertainment to cheer himself up wait
just a flee jumping moment what was that
what the big idea how did these escaped
instances of SCP 377-2 get in here
they're all supposed to be in safe
containment a few floors down did
somebody else from the research team let
them in here because they knew I was in
costume standing in front of a pretend
Fairground set that's in pretty poor
taste don't you think pun very much
intended I should probably report it to
the head researcher that would be the
ethical reasonable thing to do then
again look at them go those are sure
some hilarious dances I'm definitely
seeing a Snappy attempt at doing the
Charleston uh classic and is that one
doing the worm or is it just kind of
flopping on the floor I think one of
these instances knows about that
fortnite stuff all the kids are into
these days but I'm not sure if the human
element or the Golem that decides what
dances it knows either way this was
exactly what I needed to feel so much
better for once it feels like I'm
actually at a carnival instead of just
pretending to be at one now this is the
greatest performance I've ever seen in
all my years would you can be sure that
there have been a lot of in
1961 the SCP Foundation discovered a
town that was completely devoid of all
life not long before their arrival
darington North Carolina had been a
community with high aspirations a deeply
religious Township of devout Christians
many of whom were seeking greater
Prosperity from their lives but now
their home was a ghost town with no sign
of any prior darington resident to be
found where in the hell had they all
gone it hardly seemed like the
population of an entire town would all
simultaneously decide to up sticks and
leave to pastures new but then again
maybe the citizens of darington hadn't
left at all perhaps they weren't even
really still human and had taken up
residence somewhere much darker like
underground this is the story of one of
the earliest known instances of a
phenomenon now known under the
designation of SCP
389 or to use its alternative name that
oldtime religion when the SCP Foundation
arrived in a desolate darington to find
the town's folk had all vanished they
immediately began an investigation into
the exact how's and wise the answers to
what exactly had happened here after all
while not a huge place darington was
home to nearly a thousand residents and
that many people don't just disappear if
they even had disappeared and weren't
just dormant but what the foundation
uncovered was a gruesome discovery that
led them to not only demolishing the
entire North Carolinian town but
purchasing all the land around it to
keep the area under permanent
observation prior to the demolition
however the ministry of Sevenfold
blessing had been one of the oldest
buildings in darington much like most
Town churches and it was while searching
the offices of this church that the
foundation cleanup Crews discovered
their first piece of evidence the
initial clue about what had happened to
this deserted town they recovered a
series of cassette tapes each with a
recording of sermons that had been given
within the ministry of Sevenfold
blessing these were all delivered by One
Pastor Bartholomew Jenner the first
having been recorded on August 17th of
1959 2 years earlier my friends I want
to talk to you about what the Bible
offers tonight Pastor Jenner began in
the first of these recordings I want to
talk to you about what you are owed I
want to talk to you about I want to talk
to those of you who are struggling right
now to those of you who have hardship
and pain maybe you've heard that the
Bible only nourishes the spirit that God
only provides for our Immortal Souls
well my friends I'm here to tell you
that this is simply not true Pastor
Bartholomew Jenner seemed to be focused
on the discussion of very real relatable
problem
after all what person hasn't felt
unsatisfied with their life at one point
or another and this was apparently no
different for the people of darington
many of you can think of places in your
lives where you have not yet risen where
you are not yet Victorious marriage
finances hell but do not fret my friends
God wants you to rise he has cleared a
path for you it is one littered with his
Earthly Treasures to claim them you only
need to shed your old selves and be
reborn the bastor was merely using the
shared faith of the township to help
reaffirm that their struggles were not
the Beall end all of their lives or at
least that's how it first appeared but
the religious practices taking place in
this first recording would soon take a
bizarre turn making it clear there was
something far more Sinister even
cult-like going on in the ministry of
Sevenfold blessing now if you would some
of the ladies from the mayor's office
were kind enough to collect these cicada
shells pass along each of you take one
yes the children too be careful very
careful they are fragile each of you
take one and hold it in your left hand
yes the left hand not the right your
left the shells of dead cicas hardly
seem like common fair for a sermon like
this although as the recording continued
it was easy to understand that Pastor
Jenner intended these discarded insect
carapaces to be something of a metaphor
even if they were pretty gross
especially to some of the younger
members of his congregation he explained
to the darington residents that these
cicada shells Were Meant To Be symbolic
of whatever hardship the citizens were
currently struggling with in their lives
whether it was work a marriage or an ill
family member then came the next part of
this unorthodox practice the pastor
instructed everyone in the congregation
to picture themselves holding their
biggest problem in their left hand now I
want you to squeeze your left hand
squeeze it into a fist feel that problem
cracking like old dried out paper pH it
crumbled to dust Jenner told them the
residents of darington did so crushing
the cicada shells until there was
nothing left everyone open your eyes
don't you feel better stronger this is
what is offered our hardships are like
the shell we shall cast them aside even
as they crumble God has cleared a path
needless to say the foundation agents
that recovered the tapes of Pastor
Jenner's odd sermons weren't exactly
sure what to make of them and as unusual
as they were the recordings did little
to indicate where the town's people of
darington North Carolina had disappeared
to but as they listened further what
they found was even more unsettling than
an entire Congregation of people
crushing cicada shells in the second
recording dated December 19th of 1959
Pastor Jenner was once again presiding
over his congregation he had just
finished quoting a passage from Matthew
25:30 which related to a Biblical tale
known as the parable of the talents in
this story a master puts his servants in
charge of a differently sized portion of
his wealth while he is away then judges
them based on whether or not his
servants make a profit using his money
the third servant who had received the
least talents meaning an amount of money
was punished for burying his share in
the ground cast out into the OU of
Darkness to face weeping and nashing of
teeth it was after making mention of
this unprofitable servant that Pastor
Jenner went on to address even more more
of the bizarre almost ritualistic
practices he had been introducing to his
sermons now some of you have expressed
concerns over the new sacraments a few
have even called them sacr and yet have
we not prospered have these same
naysayers these same doubting Thomases
not profited from our good works the
pastor declared I have shown you how to
heal the sick with the Lord's Prayer and
the blood of an unbaptized child I've
shown you how to see your future in this
stemming entrails of a quivering Crow
I've shown you the path to Glory but I
cannot make you follow this path I can
only show it to you it is you and you
alone who must follow it who must rise
and shed your old SS shed your old self
the words immediately called to mind the
image of the cicas insects that discard
their outer carapaces and emerge a new
bugs that also burrow into the ground
and wait lying dormant under the Earth
for years at at a time all before they
emerge rising up again so they can
spread it was becoming clear that Pastor
Jenner was certainly deviating further
and further from the church's normal
religious practices his bold and blatant
descriptions of what sounded like
ritualistic sacrifices were shocking
enough to hear speaking of using blood
and entrails to bring the town the
prosperity it sought but if that wasn't
bad enough the worst was still yet to
come contained within the third and
final recording unlike the previous
cassettes most of the sermon from June
7th 1960 was almost completely
unintelligible and without any Visual
Evidence to go along with it it was hard
for the foundation to make out exactly
what was going on it began with another
quote from Matthew this time CH 28: 6
which made mention of the resurrection
of Jesus that he had risen and that
people should come and see where the
Lord lay not a metaphor my friends
Pastor Jenner explained before urging
his congregation to to join in some kind
of formation step forward mothers behind
their daughters fathers behind their
sons turn to face the uh recording
became unintelligible again after that
point with only a few more words being
audible the pastors seem to have
gathered the town's folk of darington
presumably for some new form of ritual
he encouraged the town's children to
close their eyes and pray before
reminding the congregation that God
sacrificed the life of his only son
Jesus frighteningly it appeared that
Pastor Jenner was implying the adults of
darington should do the same one of the
next fragments of his sermon that could
be deciphered declared lamb is
slaughtered to feed the lion the son is
slaughtered to feed between more and
more noise interfering with the
recording Pastor Jenner could be heard
saying the p is complete this world
shall be our Paradise before he
encouraged his congregation or those who
were left to dig deep and wait then came
perhaps the most horrifying part of the
tape the remainder of the recording
lasted 30 minutes comprised of pure
static or the foundation agents
listening to it assumed at first that it
was just interference but further audio
analysis seemed to suggest that the long
continuous mass of hissing wasn't static
at all it was The chittering Sound of
Insects like the noise made by cicas for
a Time the incident at darington left
the foundation baffled there seemed to
be no clear answer as to what had
happened not one of the town's residents
were anywhere to be found and on top of
that there were no bodies no remains of
any kind to speak of if they were dead
there would at least be some kind of
trace and then there were all the
questions raised by Pastor Bartholomew
Jenner's strange sermons why did he seem
so focused on enacting rituals did any
of his methods really benefit the town
and why did he place so much emphasis on
cicas of all things answers were few and
far between although almost 6 decades
after the foundation discovered the
desolate town of darington a new
development would come to light to be
more accurate it was 56 years later on
the 11th of January 2017 a foundation
agent named Daniel Mitchell was
patrolling the area that had formerly
been darington North Carolina before the
foundation had demolished all traces of
the Town by this point the SCP
Foundation had long thought that they
had figured out exactly what SCP 389 was
they had even encountered it emerging in
a number of different forms in both 2007
and
2015 however it was what Daniel Mitchell
happened across during the routine
monthly Patrol that revealed the
horrifying Truth at the outskirts of the
area where the town had once been a
series of sinkles had opened up at some
point between the previous monthly check
and this one in early 2017 and if you
think that these sinkholes caused a
disturbance in the earth and uncovered
all the bodies of the former residents
of darington you'd be wrong it was far
far far stranger the foundation
conducted a fullscale examination of the
sinkholes around the demolished North
Carolinian town and these weren't just a
few patches of loose ground that had
sunk through the Geological Survey the
foundation carried out quickly revealed
that these sinkles led to an extensive
network of tunnels underground they
extended several hundred km outwards
practically covering the entire
underside of where darington had been
the tunnels seemed far too big than any
other created by any natural means
but the entire network also appeared too
rudimentary too imperfect to have been
carved using any modern excavation
technology like a large drill plus if
any equipment like that had been on site
the foundation would have noticed as
they kept the area monitored it was
almost like something had been burrowing
through the ground only to eventually
crawl back up to the surface resulting
in the sink holes what's more the
foundation's geological tests suggested
that the network of tunnels was almost
four decades old that would have placed
the date of their creation about 10
years after The Disappearance of
everyone in darington naturally the
foundation immediately launched a
mission to explore more of the tunnels
before even completing a full sweep of
the underground space in its entirety
they had made another Discovery
contained within the tunnels was over a
whole ton of organic material that had
been mostly preserved without
decomposing too much the SCP Foundation
began Gathering samples for testing
finding most of this material to be
severely desiccated dermis tissue that
is the dense layer of skin beneath the
epidermis and it had all been entirely
dried out but that wasn't all the
testing uncovered according to genetic
analysis the tissue had two distinct
types of DNA present the first being
easily identified as human genetic
material which made sense despite the
material lacking in moisture the dermis
tissue didn't match the skin of any
other mammal but then there was the
other DNA Pres present combined with the
expected human DNA was the presence of
something else that the foundation
researchers had quite some difficulty
finding a match for eventually they
determined that this genetic material
entangled with the human DNA belonged to
the sadada Montana better known as The
New Forest cicada cicas again cicada DNA
mixed with human DNA discovered in a
large network of underground tunnels all
beneath the same town where a pastor had
congregation crushed cicada shells in
their left hands during one of his
sermons 10 years before the sinkhole
incident the foundation was alerted to a
particular YouTube channel by the name
of Kai Sanchez positively rich on the
surface Kai was one of the many online
grifters preaching about how easy it was
to quickly achieve an obscene amount of
wealth by simply believing in yourself
usually if not always these types of
people were trying to scam Their
audience of loyal subscribers into
investing in some some kind of illicit
money-making scheme or any number of
other cons promising their followers
easy money that never came but Kai
Sanchez's channel was slightly different
so much so that the foundation had to
contain his entire audience deeming them
to have been affected by SCP
3089 the video that caught the
foundation's attention was an hourlong
upload from Kai entitled seven secrets
to ascend the ladder of prosperity there
was that word again Prosperity the same
thing Pastor Jenner had promised his
entire congregation in darington and the
similarities didn't end there in his
video much like the pastor during his
sermons Kai Sanchez encouraged his
audience to visualize their success in
order to achieve it he implied that the
human consciousness could impact reality
for example if his viewers just imagined
themselves having a bigger bank account
or looking more attractive then these
things would manifest themselves into
the real world one of Kai's secrets to
ascend the ladder of prosperity was as
follows visualize your ascendants
reimagine yourself as someone who can
reach the top of that ladder shed your
old identity tear it off throw it aside
like dead skin you won't need it not
where you're going the resemblance to
Pastor Jenner's sermons was uncanny
Kai's video even encouraged that his
audience leave scraps out to lure
straight cats into their homes and then
once they had one to take a knife and
well you remember what happened in
darington but Kai Sanchez made sure to
spef
remember to hold the knife with your
left hand another online community was
tagged by the foundation for similar
teachings this group of insular men were
trying to apply the same methodology
primarily to attract women however they
also reasoned it could be used to
improve their own financial status and
physical stature all done through
visualizing and believing that doing so
would make these things improve that
having faith would grant them Prosperity
this Disturbed Community even tried to
use bug Rattlers to to emit frequencies
to Aid in attracting women contained
within these Rattlers were the preserved
remains of cicas male catas have Timbs
structures on their outer shell that
emit a loud hissing chittering noise
that they often use to find a mate after
spending so much time dormant
underground before burrowing up to the
surface and if you've been paying
attention you might be able to guess
exactly where this is going SCP 389 is a
phenomenon that occurs with in
communities of people who are seeking
some form of prosperity whether that
community be a town a group of
like-minded people online or any other
group of collected individuals the
particular type of prosperity these
people are all seeking can be anything
from spiritual enlightenment to
financial success the SCP Foundation
does not yet quite understand exactly
how SCP 389 starts only that the
communities affected by it will attempt
to achieve their chosen material Success
Through the application of rituals like
visualizing what they hope to overcome
and Achieve and practicing sacrifices in
short these people have to believe these
acts will grant them what they want they
need to be willing to go far enough to
do unspeakable things they need to have
faith although what they don't realize
is some things can feed on that Faith
they can Harvest it before these
communities realize the terrible things
that they have done or who exactly has
tricked them into performing these
rituals they'll begin to undergo a
horrific transformation process known as
SCP
389-3843 and 6 hours these people will
then suffer a change to their epidermis
the outer layer of skin it starts to
harden until it has form a dense brittle
substance like a shell next comes the
second stage of SCP 389 B metamorphosis
internally SCP 389a individuals will
develop a number of tetras a type of
germ cell tumor that can contain several
different types of tissue such as hair
muscle and bone during the next 2 or 3
weeks these tumors will expand and
dissolve the person soft tissue then
there's the final stage emergence an
instance of SCP 389a will exit its
dormant state that began in the initial
stage once they have awoken then
something exits the outer epidermal
shell it will not communicate some will
retain remnants of internal organs such
as eyes or lungs however these are
vestigal no longer serving any purpose
the brain functions deviate from any
normal human patterns having completed
the process this thing will attempt to
burrow down into the soil via any means
at its disposal an outer shell digging
into the soil the tunnels underneath
darington the genetic material uncovered
below dermis tissue with two types of
DNA a mix of human and cicada there is
something out there it is preying on
people's Faith their longing for
Prosperity then when these communities
are presented with someone who can take
advantage of that Faith Like Pastor
Jenner or Kai Sanchez they find
themselves encouraged to push their
faith to its furthest limit and then
they are rewarded by becoming something
else something nightmarish the question
is when they wake up and crawl back out
from their tunnels leaving a sinkhole in
their wake where do these cicada
creatures go everyone loves a good ghost
story whether you're crowded around a
campfire are watching a YouTube video at
3:00 a.m. there's something fun and
exciting about imagining haunted places
plagued by strange noises and
apparitions part of what makes it so fun
is the idea that any place can be
haunted especially if terrible things
have happened there that decrepit old
house at the end of your street that
80-year-old movie theater where no one
goes anymore a park where one too many
kids went missing all it takes is a
tragic backstory and a creepy atmosphere
and it's easy to believe that any place
could be teaming with Restless Spirits
so it stands to reason that a place with
as many unsolved deaths as the SCP
Foundation might have a ghost or two
lurking in the shadows if you've ever
suspected that the SCP Foundation might
be haunted well you'd be right it began
as all good ghost stories do with a
series of frightening unexplained events
some time ago Personnel at SCP
Foundation site 30 began to notice
strange things happening around the
facility obviously at a place like an
SCP Foundation containment site strange
as relative but these events seemed to
have nothing to do with any of the
entities contained at the site there
were unexplained sounds reported in the
private quarters of agents and
researchers ranging from Whispers to
screams from an unseen being Personnel
who approached the d-class block at the
site noticed an immediate drop in
temperature with some employees claiming
that they could even see their own
breath several Personnel reported items
going missing while they were alone in
the room most were small and easily
misplaced objects like pens and
clipboards but one man said his wallet
disappeared which wouldn't be that
strange if it hadn't been securely
inside his lab coat other Personnel
would be innocently washing their hands
only to be horrified by the appearance
of a bloody figure in a d-class jumpsuit
in the mirror staring back at them with
hatred in its eyes eyes there were
anomalous computer server errors the
feeling of being watched or followed by
some menacing invisible force even the
side of a shadowy silhouette fleeing
down corridors and hiding around corners
all of these occurrences were reported
to higher-ups at the foundation but they
were all dismissed the directorial board
of the site insisted that these accounts
were likely the result of employees
cracking under the immense mental stress
of working under such strenuous
circumstances if left alone they were
certain that the reports would stop but
the reports didn't stop and they soon
found out that this was only the
beginning there was an uptick in
containment breaches following these
initial reports in total 12 different
entities were released from their
containment and the origin of these
breaches could not be identified
thankfully the entities were captured
and returned to their containment
facilities before any casualties could
result but from there things kept
getting worse over the course of several
months there were were six different
employee suicides on site security
footage of the deceased operative
shortly before their death showed them
acting deeply troubled engaging an
agitated conversation with someone not
visible to the camera at first it was
posited that whoever was upsetting the
employees was in a blind spot but it
quickly became clear that the dead
employees were being tormented by
something invisible stories of hauntings
were one thing but now with escaped scps
and a notable death count the
directorial board decided to mount an
official investigation into the
Unexplained occurrences it was then that
the spirit was officially acknowledged
identified and reclassified as SCP
4973 SCP 4973 was once a d-class worker
who was used as a guinea pig in 25
different experiments with a variety of
entities on site he was reportedly
exposed to multiple unusual and
dangerous anomalies including SCP 158 a
large mechanical iCal arm capable of
extracting an unidentified substance
from any living test subject before he
was brought on board at SCP Foundation
site 30 he was also known as Gordon
carvis marovich a man who had been
convicted of murder in the second degree
after stabbing his wife 24 times in the
chest with a kitchen knife during his
incarceration marovich was transferred
to the custody of the SCP Foundation and
placed at site 30 where he was given a
new name d1000
during an experiment involving a
redacted entity d1000 was killed and his
remains were disposed of at a nearby
waste Refinery it was then only 3 months
after his death that the initial reports
of ghost activity began SCP 4973 is
regarded as a class 4 spectral entity
meaning that it is an entity displaying
a high degree of aggression and
malevolence towards a specific
individual or group in this case the
spirit displays hostility towards a very
specific specific group The SCP
Foundation class 4 entities can affect
the environment around them move objects
reduce the temperature in a room and
induce hallucinations in humans that it
comes into contact with these
hallucinations are thought to be the
cause of the increase in employee
suicides that occurred after 4973 his
first appearance one of the many ways in
which SCP 4973 acted out and what is
believed to be an attempt at revenge on
the foundation as a whole was to somehow
gain access to the skip net database
terminal this allowed the spirit to
learn about the entities contained at
the site as well as personal details
regarding the lives of research security
and administrative staff working there
this information is likely what allowed
4973 to cause several suspected
containment breaches though the
specifics of those breaches have been
expunged from official records 4973 was
eventually contained within an apparatus
known as The incorporeal Entity vacuum
chamber
which is constantly monitored by a team
of Specialists with an MTF mu13
affectionately nicknamed Ghostbusters in
order to prevent it from escaping four
Harrington Hollow neutralizer Wards have
been placed at the door to the
containment facility this containment
method has been largely effective though
the spirit had escaped a handful of
times and had to be recaptured and
placed back into the ievc in order to
understand as SCP
4973 and how it was able to access the
database Dr lorine Casper was assigned
to conduct an interview with the spirit
speaking to it as it was in containment
and a transcript of this interview was
available in the official Foundation
archives Dr Casper began the
conversation politely addressing the SCP
as Gordon and asking him how he was
Gordon refused to comply with the round
of questioning going as far as to yell
at Dr Casper until she reminded him that
he faced the risk of termination if he
refused to answer her questions Dr
Casper pointed out that the files
accessed by 4973 required clearance that
the spirit would have no way of
possessing he responded that he simply
waved his hand across the terminal in
order to access it explaining it freaked
out for a second then just stop I could
just move my fingers around the air and
the tabs would just roll up easy as that
Dr Casper asked for clarification
inquiring how he could even do something
like that 4973 continued his explanation
beats me it felt like some attraction
like magnets from afar getting closer
and closer I don't know something like
that finding this answer unsatisfactory
Dr Casper pushed further asking for an
explanation of SCP 4973 is attempts to
release dangerous on-site anomalies from
containment this question seemed to
stump him and he claimed not to
understand what Dr Casper meant she
explained that the ID cards of Dr yurov
and Dr Orson were used to open the
facilities from which these anomalies
escaped 4973 was shocked that he had
even been suspected of this attack and
insisted not to know who Orson or yurkov
even were all of a sudden he trailed off
there was silence for a moment and Dr
Casper began to collect her notes and
leave assuming that the interview was
over much to her surprise SCP 4973 began
to laugh a loud aborus laugh of complete
and utter Delight Casper asked what 4973
was laughing about and was met with the
resp response God this whole time you
and your ghost hunting crew never knew
he refused to clarify what it was the
doctor and her crew had missed only
saying God that look on your face when
you find out it's been right under your
nose this whole time he continued to
laugh at Dr Casper for the remainder of
the interview refusing to answer any
further questions or explain any of his
comments finally Dr Casper grew
exasperated and left ending the
interview for real this time following
this perplex ing interview Dr Casper
inexplicably abandoned her post at site
30 her supervisors could not reach her
neither could any of the other
researchers at the site no one had heard
from her for an entire week until one
day she called director Eric Riverson of
site 30 on his personal phone line he
recorded the conversation and a
transcript has been included in the file
for SCP
4973 Dr Casper explained to director
Riverson that she had been hiding in her
private residence away from the site and
that she no longer considered any part
of the site safe in fact she suggested
that all SCP Foundation sites might be
potentially compromised she explained
her conversation with SCP
4973 and the questions it provoked her
to ask if he had not been behind the
containment breaches then who was he
never encountered Dr yurov or Orson in
any of the tests administered on him and
Orson wasn't even employed at the
foundation until after 4973 his death Dr
Casper posited that though the spirit of
Gordon was not responsible for the
breaches another spectral force or
forces at the site might be her
hypothesis that site 30 was positively
infested with the vengeful spirits of
Class D employees lost over the years
during various experiments in order to
prove her Theory Dr Casper got her hands
on all the experimental equipment used
by the department researching spectral
anomalies the general consensus among
researchers in this field is that
Spirits leak out a kind of energy known
as ectoplasm wherever they go it has
been compared to the skin Left Behind
when a spider or a snake molds a
non-essential portion of the entity that
is shed and leaves a residue in areas
where they have been unsurprisingly a
huge amount of ectoplasm was detected
inside of site 30 the spirits were
undetected at first as many of them were
dormant for quite some time dormant
Spirits are spirits that are not aware
of their surroundings or the
circumstance ances of their deaths and
they do not emit large quantities of
ectoplasm it is likely that after Gordon
was trapped several of the dormant
spirits of site 30 began to remember
what was done to them and manifest in
more aggressive ways because Gordon was
presumed to be the only Spirit at the
site their gradual appearance and acting
out was either ignored or presumed to be
Gordon escaping from containment after
her realization Dr Casper identified an
additional five active Spirits at the
site was able to capture and contain one
of them Dr Casper warned director
rierson that there were likely far more
Spirits than just those five and it was
only a matter of time before they woke
up and became active like the others the
large amount of previous containment
breaches attributed to simple human
error becomes deeply Sinister once it is
clear that there have been vengeful
Spirits hiding in plain sight the entire
time as Gordon put it in his interview
they were just under their noses the
whole time Dr Casper's findings and the
story of site 30 present a troubling
possibility every SCP Foundation site
has used massive amounts of Class D
Personnel in human experiments with
dangerous entities and the body count at
nearly all of them is staggering if Dr
Casper is right then every single site
has the makings of a haunted house all
of them could be infested with the
spirits of dead angry d-class who are
just waiting to wake up and take their
revenge on the still living members of
the organization that killed them and
it's only a matter of time before they
get the chance climbers attempting to
summon Mount Everest and stand on the
top of the world have their work cut out
for them dangers are everywhere on the
long climb there's a risk of extreme
altitude sickness unpredictable winds
and freezing weather there's also the
threat of avalanches great Unstoppable
tidal waves of snow that can bury a
person alive in seconds or strand them
leaving them to freeze to death cold and
alone it's a sad reality that not
everyone that visits Everest comes back
down again and rarely does a climbing
season go by that the mountain doesn't
claim yet another victim situated on the
border between China and Nepal in a
subrange of the Himalayas of Tibet
Everest is one of the seven wonders of
the natural world with an elevation of
29,31 Ft or
8,848 M Mount Everest has a attracted
many experienced mountain climbers over
the decades but even for the most
experienced Mountaineers the Ascension
up its snowy slopes is far from Easy
deaths occurring on Mount Everest are
nothing new and hundreds of people are
believed to have died attempting to
ascend the treacherous Peak sadly due to
the risks involved with carrying heavy
loads down off the mountain many of
those who die on Evers are doomed to
stay there forever their frozen bodies
serving up as their own grave markers
it's difficult enough to move your own
body up and down Everest and in many
situations bringing a body back down is
simply impossible the bodies of these
lost souls are scattered all across and
sometimes underneath the surface of
Mount Everest but some of those bodies
are different from the others and have a
special name within the files of the SCP
Foundation they call them SCP
5140 SCP 5140 is the designation given
to a number of frozen bodies which are
found on across Everest it is unclear
exactly how many instances of SCP 5140
there are though some estimates have
placed the number at somewhere between 1
and 200 at present it is unknown if all
the instances of SCP 5140 are dead
bodies belonging to climbers who met
tragedy on the tallest mountain in the
world or if some of them are something
else entirely but while their origin is
unclear if you come into contact with a
5140 instance there won't be any doubt
that it's different from the normal body
of a dead climber that's because SCP
5140 corpses are a lot like vampires in
some ways that isn't to say that they
actually are vampires they certainly are
not Undead and cannot function after
death but much like a vampire
traditionally drains blood to survive
these bodies drain heat SCP 5140 corpses
are ectoentropic meaning they do not
adhere to the normal laws of
thermodynamics whenever these cavers are
exposed to sources of heat including
human body heat the corpse will
instantly drain the source of any and
all thermal energy however the
temperature of these SCP 5140 bodies
remains the same regardless of how much
heat they are able to drain staying at a
constant 50° F or 10° C should any
living person come into direct contact
with one of the SCP 5140 corpses the
body will absorb their natural body heat
bring bringing their victim's own
temperature down to 10° C and causing
them to die and once they have died
their body then becomes a new instance
of SCP 5140 as a quick side note this
might feel vaguely reminiscent of
another anomaly which features seemingly
inert dead bodies that are hazardous to
anyone around them SCP
2316 this anomaly is a powerful mimetic
Hazard consisting of a large number of
drowned human corpses these Cor are
extremely hazardous to approach at even
a considerable distance as the mimetic
hazard inherent to the anomaly causes
those affected to recognize the bodies
in the water as people they know
particularly from their childhood like a
siren Call the victims are lured into
the water believing that the familiar
bodies are calling to them if the
victims aren't stopped quarantined and
given amnestic treatment they are
essentially considered lost they will
walk into the water and be absorbed into
the collective becoming just another
body floating in the water while the
foundation doesn't currently believe
that there is any official connection
between the two anomalies the
similarities are undeniable and worth
taking into consideration moving on at
present it is unclear whether SCP 5140
corpses are caused by some sort of
infection or parasite that spreads among
the bodies uncovered at Mount Everest if
this is the case the foundation has yet
to uncover the patient zero the root
cause of these infected bodies there is
also little to determine why a deceased
body requires the absorption of heat as
well as how it achieves this and also
keeps its own temperature low but not
frozen given that interacting with an
instance of SCP 5140 can be fatal it
does seem that these anomalous
properties can be passed through contact
and exposure like a disease or a
parasite but there have been no observed
anomalous effects among any living
person visiting Mount Everest there is a
possibility that the SCP 5140 corpses
have developed some form of postumus
mutation that has come as a result of
being killed during an Everest avalanche
and buried in the snow their bodies
starved of heat after death after all
Everest is known for its cold
temperatures occasionally reaching as
low as 1° F or
-7° C not to mention the difference in
air pressure at such high altitudes as
well as frequent high-speed freezing
cold winds at the summit of Mount
Everest wind speeds can reach up to 280
kmph that is equivalent to
175 mph and high speed winds have even
been known to catch mountain climbers
off guard and send them plummeting to
their deaths perhaps the combination of
these conditions the freezing
temperature the air pressure and the
winds have triggered some sort of change
in a number of the bodies unfortunate
enough to never leave the snow covered
slopes of Mount Everest either that or
these abandoned corpses left in such
extreme dream cold could be the perfect
home maybe some form of unknown and so
far undetected parasite is capable of
inhabiting these frozen bodies and can
spread to other living hosts by draining
them of their body heat stranger things
have certainly happened at the SCP
Foundation and that could possibly
explain why anyone interacting with an
SCP 5140 corpse meets the same Grizzly
fate regardless of what causes these
abnormalities or why the SCP 5140 bodies
have only been UNC covered at Mount
Everest close contact with the corpses
often result in casualties and
fatalities naturally this is a cost the
SCP Foundation likes to avoid as often
as it can the nasty habit SCP 5140
corpses have of draining a person's body
heat makes it impractical to bring them
back to a foundation research facility
for testing as does the fact that
they're on the tallest mountain in the
world instead MTF Delta 14 have been
tasked with keeping these heat thirsty
cavas contained to Mount Everest
mobile task force Delta 14 also known
under the code name Winter Wonderland is
formed of a group of particularly Adept
Mountaineers and experts in
understanding and adapting to
particularly brutal terrain without
drawing attention to themselves these
covert operatives are tasked with
periodically climbing Mount Everest and
keeping SCP 5140 contained it is this
team's job to locate any new instance of
SCP 5140 bodies and bury them in the
snow in doing so the goal is to prevent
any witting mountain climbers from
stumbling upon one of these bodies and
potentially becoming a new instance
themselves meanwhile the foundation is
pushing for both Nepal and Tibet to
tighten restrictions on climbing permits
but of course the money that Mount
Everest tourism brings to these two
countries has likely impeded this
according to the foundation's file on
SCP 5140 an incident occurred during one
of mobile task force Delta 14's annual
Everest Expeditions members of MTF Delta
14 had been triing ring towards the
Everest summit encountering more and
more of the SCP 5140 bodies as they made
their way up the mountain just as they
were instructed to do so the team buried
each of the Frozen corpses they came
across under a blanket of snow the Delta
14s noticed though that there had been a
much higher number of the frosty cavers
on this Mission speculating that perhaps
Mount Everest's high winds had blown the
snow off of ones they had already buried
on previous missions one of the Delta
14s a man named Charlie Smith was Inc
respondents with his colleagues at their
base camp Charlie reported that one of
his fellow winter wonderlands Patrick
had touched one of the SCP 5140 corpses
when the team reached the summit and
that he was now buried according to
protocols after becoming an SCP 5140
instance himself as they began their
descent from a top Everest Charlie sent
an urgent communication to base camp
reporting that he' uncovered three more
SCP 5140 bodies at an abandoned campsite
except these three instances were
different from any he had encountered
before these corpses Were Somehow still
moving attempting to hurry down the
mountain Charlie reported that a mass of
SCP 5140 corpses were blocking his path
and draining another one of his
squadmates Arnold of his body heat to
make him one of them Arnold had been
carrying the team's Provisions including
their oxygen reserves to combat the lack
of breathable Air at Mount Everest's
high altitude Charlie tried in vain to
use his flare gun to clear the path
hoping to distract the now walking
cavers with a heat Source but it had no
effect his final message to base camp
warned the rest of Delta 14 to not come
to the summit of Everest with Charlie
frantically urging them to not let
climbers anywhere near it his final
message simply stated that the mountain
is danger a rescue division of mobile
task force Delta 14 arrived just under 2
hours later tracking Charlie's last
known location via a GPS Beacon
strangely despite the Frantic messages
from Charlie there were no signs of any
SCP 5140 instances none of the piles of
corpses he had warned them about could
be seen above the snow and certainly
none of them were moving it wasn't long
before the rescue team found Charlie
though he was dead but not drained of
heat or turned into another instance of
SCP 5140 no sadly after bringing their
fallen comrade back to base an autopsy
revealed that Charlie had died likely
the same way so many other Climbers on
Everest had he had suffered from a lack
of oxygen further exam mintion of his
gear revealed that Charlie's oxygen
intake valve had been damaged earlier
while the squad had been climbing to the
summit of Mount Everest his teammates
Arnold Hillary and Patrick Edmund were
also discovered on the mountain but only
Patrick had been turned into an SCP 5140
instance Arnold had simply died from
exposure just like Charlie the rescue
team concluded that due to lack of
adequate oxygen Charlie Smith had
hallucinated the sight of SCP 5140
corpses moving and blocking his path
spending his final moments in Terror as
as the mountains conditions slowly
killed him the foundation is still
unsure exactly what caused his bodies to
become instances of SCP 5140 or even how
many of them are on Everest but a major
and troubling development has recently
been made after an increase in global
temperature led to a large Avalanche
that resulted in a large portion of the
mountain that had previously been
covered in thick snow being exposed the
foundation sent planes that were
equipped with thermal imaging equipment
to scan the mountain what they found was
as confusing as was terrifying the SCP
5140 corpses aren't just spread across
the surface of Mount Everest they are
much of Everest the mountain itself is
just a huge pile of corpses just waiting
to drain the life from anyone who
attempts to scale it and turn them into
a permanent part of the peak so if you
were planning a trip to the Himalayas
hoping to scratch climb Mount Everest
off your bucket list maybe give it a
pass otherwise you might find that the
climb is even colder than you were
expecting ing the thin pale humanoid
anomaly had just found itself in
Minecraft of all places the all two
familiar whale of emergency alarms rang
out through the corridors of the
foundation facility it had happened
again another containment breach of
course the on-site Personnel were more
than familiar with the protocols for a
situation like this so well versed in
what to do during an emergency that it
had become second nature whether they
were research staff evacuating for their
own safety or security teams moving in
to recapture the escaped anomaly and get
the situation under control everyone was
moving like they had been programmed
muscle memory taking over the loose
anomaly was none other than scp096 all
Foundation Personnel were alerted and
reminded not to look directly at the
creature there was just one problem they
couldn't look even if they'd ignored
their order to try nobody could because
the shy guy was nowhere to be found well
nowhere in the real world at least this
whole situation bizarre even by
Foundation standards had all started
with an experiment involving a member of
the Disposable d-class Personnel yet
another dangerous convict serving one of
several life sentences now being used as
an Expendable human lab rat for the
foundation's often Sinister purposes the
experiment in question was an attempt to
further test the limitation of SCP 96's
abilities by now the foundation had done
extensive research in to the creature
known as the shy guy they knew its
particular brand of anomalous qualities
were triggered when anyone looked
directly at it being observed would
instantaneously send scp096 into an
uncontrollable rage State causing it to
pursue its Observer until they were no
longer standing scp096 was known to be
able to travel at speed so relentless it
was pretty much impossible to stop one
moment it was sobbing and screeching in
its cell having just been observed and
minutes later the wide jawed long limed
monster was standing behind whoever had
seen it making its screaming face the
image its victim took to the Grave with
them Foundation researchers knew that
scp-096's rage State could be triggered
by as little as someone seeing the
slightest hint of a creature even if the
shy guy had been captured as a tiny
Speck in the background of a photograph
it would come after anyone whose eyes so
much as glanced over that Speck it also
didn't matter how far away the OB server
was scp096 could not be outrun it could
track down anyone wherever they were in
the world but what if a person who had
observed the shy guy was no longer in
the world the experiment had taken a lot
of trial and error after all digitizing
a human being and transforming their
entire Consciousness into code was no
easy task but the foundation wasn't
above breaking more than a few eggs to
make an omelet especially when those
eggs were the brains of a few d-class
Personnel at actually the first test
subjects turned out more scrambled or
fried certainly overdone given the
amount of smoke coming from their ears
but eventually the research team had
perfected the device they dubbed the
neural harness a headset that could
translate a person's mind into pure
digital code their Consciousness would
be extracted from their body leaving
their physical form an empty shell while
a digital copy of them was able to
Traverse the local on-site computer
network of course the foundation wasn't
about to let a digiti declass run a muuk
with their systems so their coding
experts wrote a number of specialized
parameters into their successful test
subject now the digital d-class could be
programmed to follow the foundation
directive from his perspective it was
like he was floating through cyberspace
towards the system that the foundation
had directed him to a surveillance
camera inside scp096 cell that usually
remained inactive but not today the
camera blinked to life as soon as the
d-class is cod Road based Consciousness
reached it and through it he was able to
observe as scp096 sitting against the
far wall of its containment chamber
gently whimpering and walking back and
forth that is until the creature felt
that same familiar sensation of being
watched it stood up enraged wailing
uncontrollably as the d-class watched
from within the camera then a split
second later scp096 appeared to Blink
out of existence it hadn't work the
experiment had failed and the digital
d-class began to panic before the
foundation coders could stop him he
frantically scoured the local network
for anything some kind of Escape Route
back into the real world maybe he
thought if he could get back into his
body it wouldn't count technically his
digital self was separate from his
physical form so he might get out of SCP
96's clutches on a technicality but it
was impossible his body was already
burned out by the neural harness there
was no way for the d-class to transfer
himself back there was only one option
left hide and as it turned out someone
had forgotten to uninstall a certain
building game from a computer in one of
the foundation doctor's offices the DCL
classes digitized mind zapped him into
Minecraft from his point of view it was
like he existed within the game itself
he did a computerized equivalent of
breathing a sigh of relief only to take
back all those ones and zeros in a
horrified gasp as he noticed a tall wiry
framed figure before him it hadn't
worked scp096 had still managed to
follow him into Minecraft even in a
world of computer code the shyy was able
to dispatch its digital Observer quite
easily and what had once been a living
human mind in the form of binary code
was quickly deleted but that's when
scp096 started to take notice of its
surroundings but the most recent person
to see it gone it had the chance to
actually take in where it was the bright
rays of warm light coming down from a cu
cube-shaped Sun reveal a welcoming
landscape all around constructed
entirely from cubes it fascinated scp096
instilling a kind of childlike Wonder in
the shy guy the likes of which it hadn't
experienced since well since it couldn't
remember when rather than leaving
instantly reappearing in its containment
chamber scp096 made the conscious
decision to start exploring there was a
mountainous biome surrounding scp096
Stony spire reaching up towards a clear
sky with a waterfall cascading its way
down the nearest of them at the foot of
the mountains was the opening of a cave
which the shy guy found itself wandering
towards the light from the sun while a
pleasant and welcoming change to the
surroundings it was used to was a little
harsh on scp096 is sunken eyes so
instead it began to gravitate towards
the shadowy confines of the caves not
unlike the usual darkness of its
containment chamber back at the
foundation traversing through long
winding corridors of stone as CP 096
found itself having to bend down to
avoid hitting its head on the Cave's low
ceiling obviously this formation of
Rocky blocks had informed with someone
of the shy gu's height in mind there was
a low Warm Glow coming from the farthest
side of the tunnel and the thin creature
made its way closer and closer despite
the stone walls around it feeling like a
tighter confinement than its cell
approaching the source of the light
scp096 was relieved at the cave opened
out into a more spacious area the cramp
tunnel giving way to an expansive
chamber that lay within the heart of the
mountain the warm orangey glow that had
been coming from a flowing stream of
boiling hot lava that seemed to trickle
down from somewhere above creating a
deadly fiery pool directly in the Shy
Guy's path but just before it could turn
back and leave the cave through the way
he came scp096 sensed that familiar
feeling of something observing him
across the lava pool pool on the other
side was a creature comprised of a green
Cube for a head with a long armless
cuboid body and four cubed feet if it
had been present in the real world it
might have been made out of leaves like
a living shrub it was staring directly
at the shy guy from across the lava only
for this strange newcomer to disappear a
moment later the creeper hissed before
it realized that scp096 had leaped up
behind it to land a fatal blow but
little did the infamously anxious
anomaly realize that the s shrub wasn't
done there was a colossal boom that
caused scp096 to stagger backwards
whimpering at the sudden loud explosion
and the pain that had accompanied it the
creeper had blown itself to Pieces but
in doing so had left a lasting injury
that caused scp096 considerable
discomfort as it began limping towards
the cave that led out the opposite side
of the mountain despite its injury the
shy guy was still able to move with
relative ease and the further it went
the more it seemed to gradually heal
however it was as it stepped out once
more into the sunlight that the creature
realized just how hungry it was back in
the real world it hadn't eaten for
several hours and surprisingly even
while accidentally stuck in digitized
form the hunger mechanics of Minecraft
were having an effect on scp096 the shy
guy started searching around for
anything that could prove to satiate its
hunger there was a Grove of trees not
far so SCP 09 six lumbered to take a
closer look it couldn't be certain but
it felt there was at least a slim chance
that there were apples growing amongst
the leaves but even at the anomaly's own
elongated height it couldn't simply
reach up to pick them however it was
while swiping its arms up at the tree
that the shy guy swung its Fist and
knocked at the tree trunk to the
creature's surprise he was able to chip
away at the wood with its hands punching
at the tree until the trunk had been
reduced to a collection of wooden blocks
that the shy guy was able to collect and
sure enough some red apples dropped from
the leaves above enough to quell the
hunger that scp096 was feeling at least
for the time being nearby something was
moving through the trees it was yet to
lock eyes on scp096 but the second it
did the mob would surely have sealed its
own fate as it moved around minding its
own business the tall figure overheard
the sounds of the shy guy eating and its
attention was drawn to where the
creature was standing enjoying an apple
sensing that it had been seen as CP 096
turned and locked eyes with the entity
it was perhaps the only other being in
Minecraft that was a similar height and
stature to the anomaly itself in fact
the pair were strikingly similar before
scp096 could carry out its usual method
of attack the Enderman suddenly
teleported out of view but it was too
late now both it and the shy guy had
looked at the other's face both had been
provoked and were compelled to react in
exactly the same way just as scp096
entered its rage State the Enderman 2
opened its mouth and began to shake
making loud lengthy sounds not to
similar to the Shy Guy's own angered
screams but something profoundly strange
happened next scp096 and the Endermen
kept attempting to pursue one another
appearing in a new location within the
Minecraft world neither one getting
close enough to the other they'd
teleport only for the other to teleport
away the moment they saw each other each
trying to catch one another but all
staying one step behind this rapid Chase
almost became a strange ongoing sort of
teleporting dance between scp096 and the
Enderman at first the shy guy had been
compelled to attack the Enderman like it
was with any who looked directly at it
but as they appeared and disappeared
from place to place the creature started
to feel an odd kinship with this shadowy
fellow it was so used to being
frightened and alone to its overwhelming
feelings of insecurity and self-loathing
that the simplicity of just traversing
the open world with a creature very
alike itself in many ways it had all
come as a welcome change scp096 found it
therapeutic even and before long was
following the Enderman not out of any
intention to do it harm but just to feel
for a little while like it had a friend
just a little bit longer as scp096
thought welcoming the enjoyment it felt
playing this game of Minecraft when you
work for the Foundation you need to be
ready for anything that's why as part of
the elite foundation training regimen
senior researchers and guards are always
running tests even against things that
aren't recorded anomalies under the
offices of the foundation that's why
today for a real change of pace here at
SCP explained we're not talking about
the SCP Foundation we're talking about
madeup monster stories crowdsourced over
the Internet we're seeing how the
foundation might Fair against iconic
Creepy Pasta monsters and Maniacs like
Herobrine Jeff the Killer the Slenderman
isas Jack smile dog and many many more
we've even created all new mobile task
forces to take each one down so could
any of them best the foundation's best
and brightest let's take a look and find
out and be sure to tell us which is your
favorite Creepy Pasta entity down in the
comments below let's get creepy Jeff the
Killer first up we've got everyone's
favorite disfigured knife wielding
homicidal teenager whether it's his
terrifying Visage or the iconic go to
sleep catchphrase that's forever carved
into your mind there are probably a lot
of people out there who have lost nights
of sleep worrying that this pale-faced
monster could be crawling through their
window but we know what you're probably
wondering isn't Jeff just a serial
killer why would the SCP Foundation use
up its time chasing down any old regular
human murderer we'd ask for you to think
again Jeff has displayed Feats that
clearly Mark him as anomalous despite
suffering debilitating Burns to his face
and body he still shows superhuman
strength agility and durability he's
also able to see without eyelids
suggesting some Supernatural element is
at play victims have also reported him
dodging shotgun blasts while stalking
prey so how would the foundation catch
him seeing as Jeff's modus operandi is
breaking into the homes of his victims
while they sleep the best method would
be staking out a neighborhood where he's
been shown to be active keeping close
observations on houses and even setting
up Personnel for mobile task force Sigma
9 my name is Jeff in vacant houses as
honey traps Jeff is undeniably strong
fast and tough but if attacked and
surrounded by operatives with Superior
Tactics he could be subdued without
casualties then it would just be a
matter of transferring him to a standard
high security humanoid containment cell
speaking of horrifying creatures that
come to you in the dead of night The
Rake this Supernatural entity has been
around for almost a thousand years as
far as scattered reports are aware it's
also been reported across four
continents and a huge number of
locations within those continents though
most recently it's been reported in
rural New York State and Idaho in the
early 2000s The Rake is an inhuman Beast
most often known for its large
frightening eyes and its long rake likee
claws not only does the monster feed on
human beings but it also produces a
traumatic level of fear in its victims
thankfully an entity like this is far
more familiar territory for the SCP
Foundation using their state-of-the-art
WebCrawler software they could catalog
reported sightings as they happen and
use clusters of these sting ings to
triangulate the location of the rake and
dispatch field agents to perform
reconnaissance missions from there it
would just be a matter of waiting to
strike and sending in Mobile task force
Zeta 13 rake steppers fitted with Dr
Dan's scramble goggles to prevent them
from being affected by the seemingly
Cognito hazardous effects of viewing the
rake when the creature is placed in
containment and kept in a state of
Perpetual bright light it would simply
be a matter of applying a Scranton
reality anchor to prevent the creature
from somehow phasing out of containment
just make sure you avoid its big staring
eyes in the meantime though that won't
be a problem with the next Creepy Pasta
monster isas Jack this stealthy creature
has its no eyes on one thing and one
thing only your kidneys and unless you
want to die or spend the rest of your
life on a dialysis machine we recommend
you keep your distance from him he's
discreet devious and diabolical and if
you wake up in the middle of the night
to see him staring down at you it may be
the last time your body's able to filter
toxins out of its blood naturally
thankfully we have a way to make the
foundation put a stop to his organ
harvesting ways sometimes to catch a
jack you need to use a jack there's no
way to catch isas Jack without delicious
live kidney bait so we'd recommend
sending in someone who has kidneys to
spare Dr Jack brigh brigh could be the
perfect bait without losing his life
luring idolist Jack into a decoy house
while mobile task force gamma 391 Hit
the Road Jack prepares to Spring their
cunning trap and plunge this unpleasant
kidney muncher into a humanoid
containment cell forever but our next
Creepy Pasta entity doesn't want your
kidneys it wants your life Smile Dog our
next entity seems like a harmless little
JPEG to the untrained eye a little a
little freaky sure but nothing to lose
your mind over but we know that there's
far more to this grinning husky than
meets the eye if some reports are to be
believed this image may even be
connected to the Devil Himself if you're
unlucky enough to see this image in the
world it may already be too late for you
those who see it typically as an email
attachment from a mysterious address
spend the last week of their life in a
hell of the Mind before eventually
succumbing to O Bleak and mysterious
death it's a classic Cognito hazardous
image and the most frightening part is
that it's self-propagating with one of
the only ways to even mildly alleviate
the effects seeming to be spreading the
word by subjecting another person to
this nightmare that's when we bring in
Mobile task force row 19 Naughty Dog an
elite group of hardened military
programmers handpicked from the cia's
cyber warfare unit they use their very
particular set of skills to design
WebCrawler software that Roots out and
takes down Smile Dog images across the
web and hopefully one day find the
origin of this whole thing the next
creature on the other hand we've given
up on finding the origin of that the
expressionless this entity kind of looks
like a terrifying store window mannequin
except rather than modeling fast fashion
she prefers to swallow cat's hole and
murder hospital staff oh and she also
calls herself gun mod isn't she just so
quirky her primary abilities seem to be
extreme strength and large sharp teeth
that will easily Ren through human flesh
thankfully not anything the SCP
Foundation hasn't dealt with countless
times before seeing as the only recorded
incident involving the expression list
took place at a hospital in Los Angeles
that would be the most sensible area to
stake out a detail from the creatur's
original encounter is also telling it
reacted severely to the doctor's attempt
attempts to sedate it implying that
chemical sedation is an effective method
of incapacitating the beast that's why
every member of mobile task force Kappa
99 ain't no dummy is a sharpshooter with
a tranquilizer rifle capable of putting
a hippo to sleep with a single shot
she'll probably feel less like a god in
her containment cell but while this
monster is expressionless the next one
has one very notable expression Mr
Widemouth compared to some of our other
Creepy Pasta contenders Mr Widemouth may
not look like much but that our dear
friends is exactly what this nasty
little malactor wants you to think he
may look like Gizmo's slightly demented
cousin but his intentions are even more
Sinister than that of your average
Gremlin if you're a kid home on a sick
day Mr Widemouth might strike up a
conversation after gaining your trust
he'll try to lure you to his special
place beyond the trees for some fun but
take it from us all you'll find out
there is your doom this crafty little
creep small stature and manipulative
stealth abilities might pose somewhat of
a challenge for the SCP Foundation but
that doesn't mean they can't get him
with a little intelligence and elbow
grease mobile task force Alpha 18 the
smile Smashers will follow reports of
children disappearing from their
isolated homes under mysterious
circumstances then using an extra
strength butterfly net straight from the
folks at Foundation R and D they can
chase down and capture the nasty little
monster but that won't be the case for
this next demonic offering no this
Creepy Pasta Legend is the one that
captures you no end house in recent
years there's been a spike in interest
in so-called extreme haunted houses if
you're not sure what these places are
like basically picture a CIA black site
with the occasional plastic skeleton
it's all waterboarding stress positions
and car batteries but even those places
are nothing compared to the nightmare of
no end house it's a moving possibly even
sentient spatial anomaly hiding in a
haunted house attraction and if you find
yourself inside best believe you're
never going to see the outside ever
again thankfully mobile task force Delta
35 Mam's Bane are on the case around
Halloween every year they use web
crawlers to detect chatter around no end
House events so they can swoop in and
intercept preventing helpless Thrill
Seekers from being devoured by the house
and providing amnestic treatment for
anyone who has too close of a call sadly
the foundation will not be able to
provide refunds for those who already
paid speaking of paying you'll really
pay if you end up in our next Creepy
Pasta location of Doom abandoned by
Disney mowgli's kingdom an abandoned
tropical Disney attraction based on The
Jungle Book movie is a is abandoned for
a reason it's a hot bed for anomalous
activity including freakishly large
mutant snakes reports of ghostly
activity and most prominent of all a
terrifying Photon negative Mickey Mouse
that stalks any hapless Urban explorers
who happen to find their way onto the
site of course the Walt Disney
Corporation keeps it all hush hush and
the SCP Foundation is happy to give them
a hand on that front even if the
frightening photo negative Mickey was
removed from the site it's likely the
other may appear and continue haunting
the site and seeing that the site cannot
be moved as a whole the foundation's
best bet is to form a perimeter around
the abandoned Disney attraction
preventing anything normal from getting
in and anything abnormal from getting
out mobile task force Omega 17 sons of
shikan are ever Vigilant and maintain a
strong presence in the surrounding area
but you don't need to go anywhere for
this next anomalous Terror if you're a
big Nintendo fan it might be sitting in
your house right now Ben Drowned this
haunted anys cartridge of The Legend of
Zelda Majora's Mask contains the
Restless Spirit of its last owner a guy
named Ben who well drowned if you slot
This creepy little gaming experience
into your Nintendo Entertainment System
you'll soon find that the soul of Ben is
communicating with you directly telling
you about how he died and why his
Consciousness Liv lingers on embedded in
the code of the game thankfully other
than the psychological trauma of
experiencing the game you're un likely
to be actually harmed by playing it
however mobile task force beta 51 Gamers
don't have rights are still on the case
they'll try to intercept all cursed
copies of the game and administer
amnestics to anyone who is unfortunate
enough to play it while it is still
undeniably spooky it does feel like a
relief to finally find a safe class
anomaly on on this list the same can
sadly not be said about our next
creature the Goatman if you're a fan of
camping then this malicious mimic is
going to be your worst nightmare this
monster has existed as a fixture of
Terror in everything from a number of
Native American mythologies to iconic
4chan greenex posts you may be thinking
oh What's So Scary About a goat but this
thing is no goat aside from the fact
that it's the greatest of all time at
getting you to crap your cargo shorts in
the woods first you'll smell blood in
the air and then feel an odd electrical
static like the feeling all around you
right before a lightning strike then
you'll hear noises strange noises
something not quite like a voice like an
animal throat straining to form human
words that's when you might notice your
group of friends has one more person
than you remembered and the one thing
worse than noticing that is not noticing
it because if you don't you may end up
as the shape-shifting goat man's latest
victim mobile task force Theta 11 got
your goat are constantly on the hunt for
this one but its extreme intelligence
and ethereal nature make it a nightmare
to track but forget nightmares to track
it's time for Laughing Jack this candy
stripe clown from hell is a really nasty
customer definitely do not engage unless
you've got a Scranton reality anchor on
hand and you've got a backup from
members of mobile task force Iota 40 put
Jack in the Box as a former imaginary
friend gone Rogue Laughing Jack is a
semi intangible reality warper of
considerable power he targets his
victims with sadistic Glee pulling them
into his dark carnival to experience all
kinds of nasty tortures Laughing Jack
shows No Remorse giggling while
committing every evil act you can
imagine you'll probably only find this
clown funny if you're already a depraved
serial killer and his sense of humor is
likely to utterly break your mind unless
you've been given amnestic treatment
from the SCP Foundation this is an
anomaly that would probably get along
swimmingly with SCP 106 the old man they
could chat over a few drinks one evening
and share notes on how to cause the
maximum pain to their hapless victims
that being said few people understand
maximum pain more than the next
horrifying Abomination on our roster The
Rush sleep experiment test subjects as
anyone familiar with the work of Gru
division P will tell you the Soviets
performed some pretty horrific occult
activities throughout the 20th century
one of the most disturbing of these was
the infamous Russian sleep experiment
where in a group of unfortunate
political prisoners were doused on a
classified anomalous gas that robbed
them of their ability to sleep a
chemical compound that the scientists
hope might increase the productivity of
their workers and soldiers by
eliminating sleep instead over several
terrifying days the chemical and the
sleep deprivation that ensued caused the
subjects to instead become demonic
monsters while current accounts of the
story suggest that all the subjects were
killed we can't say for sure there
weren't more out there or that the
experiment hasn't been repeated as such
mobile task force Omicron 8 night night
is constantly on the lookout for
freakish skeletal men wandering through
the woods
never sleeping outside the dark forests
where Siberian Googs used to be based
better safe than sorry right though of
course you won't feel safe at all if you
spent your childhood watching scaring
media like horror movies or Eerie SCP
YouTube channels like And subscribe by
the way or scariest of all a strange
little puppet show called Candle Cove
feel little chill go down your spine oh
yes you remember this show don't you you
love seeing all those cute little
puppets going on swashbuckling pirate
Journeys on their adorable boat the
laughing stock though there was always
that villain wasn't there you think his
name was Jawbone but that's not what you
called him you called him the skin taker
because he always had that long cloak
made of tanned human skin you also
remember that one episode that was just
all the characters screaming I mean how
could you possibly forget and most of
all you remember asking your mom about
it and her telling you that you never
actually watched a show called Candle
Cove you just sat around watching static
for hours on end of course the SCP
Foundation keeps close Taps on
everything related to this traumatic
childhood memory broadcasts of the show
are seemingly impossible to contain all
the foundation can really do is track
down people who have seen it and provide
amnestic treatment though trust us there
are things that will make your childhood
far worse worse than just watching
Candle Cove like running into this next
iconic monster the Slender Man this
terrifying entity is powerful as he is
Iconic a shape-shifting faceless
tentacled Nightmare and a threepiece
suit who likes to hide in forests and
abandon buildings either stealing
children away or influencing their minds
until they become his proxies
Supernatural servants who do anything
their inhuman Master asks them too the
Slenderman is one of the most powerful
monsters in all of creepy pasta so the
foundation certainly has their hands
full with keeping his tentacles Under
Wraps all that mobile task force ch90
Marble Hornets can do is track sightings
and keep children out of the woods when
the danger of potential Slenderman
encounters arises getting him actually
contained basically seems out of the
question after all this we might need to
relax maybe grabbing a nice sugar-free
soda and playing a session of Minecraft
might make us feel better we'll be safe
there right well probably unless we
encounter Herobrine the SCP Foundation
funnily enough is actually no stranger
to anomalies trapped in Minecraft
they've got SCP 4335 a welt in The
Crucible to thank for that but this
Minecraft horror story is a little more
personal Herobrine is a mysterious user
with the Minecraft default skin except
with one difference compl completely
white eyes this mysterious figure
invades different Minecraft servers
acting incredibly strange towards the
people who created them what makes this
more than just some random troll well
according to Legends Herobrine is the
manifestation of the Dead Brother of
Minecraft creator Notch naturally the
foundation doesn't want people running
into ghosts on Minecraft so they
dispatch mobile task force chai 69
blocked and reported to quarantine any
servers where Herobrine is cited did and
spread misinformation that the crafty
little entity had never actually existed
in the first place what is the truth of
the situation it's unclear and that's
exactly how the foundation likes it so
there we have it folks how the SCP
Foundation would counteract some of the
most infamous Creepy Pasta creeps and
creatures out there which was your
favorite do we miss any and would you
like to see any of these expanded into a
full video in the future let us know
down in the comments if you dare
what's in a name ancient folklore and
fairy tales sometimes tell of the
importance of names that they can hold
the power to summon or banish whether
you buy into the Superstition or not
you'd be unwise to ignore the power a
name can have especially if you ever
dare to venture into SCP 4000 why use
your own name too many times in this
extra-dimensional forest and you may
find that what walks out isn't you at
all at at least once a year the
foundation leads an expedition into SCP
4000 to explore this keer class
Dimension but if you go down to those
woods today then you'd better follow the
rules remember the foundation has
implemented these guidelines for your
own safety and it's in your best
interests to follow them first and
foremost when referencing anything
inside SCP 4000 be it a person place or
thing you cannot under any circumstances
use names or titles communication is key
when exploring SCP 4000 and making use
of specific spe ific descriptors will
deter any adverse effects on your
journey for example you may want to
refer to the location of SCP 4000 as the
woods where you need to speak carefully
an apt description for such a place of
course there is a reason the foundation
doesn't provide a handy flash card of
alternative descriptors for any
Personnel taking part in the annual
Mission into SCP 4000 nothing found
there can be referred to with any
consistent name so it's perhaps
advisable to look over at thesaurus and
expand your vocabulary before visiting
SCP 4000 as you'll need to come up with
a lot of different ways to refer to the
people and creatures around you but
don't worry the foundation will be able
to train you how to properly refer to
SCP 4000 in both written and verbal
communication in a similar vein the
second rule states that no Personnel
member should respond to their own name
while in SCP 4000 naturally you and your
fellow Expedition team will not be alone
in the forest you find yourselves in the
Denis of SCP 4000 are perpetually
mutating creatures some appearing to be
trustworthy While others are hostile it
is for personnel members own safety that
no consistent names or titles are used
to refer to each other in conversation
this has been known to cause Personnel
returning from SCP 4000 to experience
Vivid hallucinations and in some
instances has led to the appearances of
creatures found in SCP 4000 in our world
thirdly when interacting with the life
forms residing in SCP 4000 Personnel are
advised to accept any gifts that they're
offered but are warned to under no
circumstances consume anything that is
given to them while inside the forest
finally and above all do not divulge any
name nickname Coden name Alias or any
other personal designation when
interacting with any native entities and
disregard any designator that an
inhabitant of SCP 4000 attempts to
assign to you personnel must however
remain courteous in the presence of any
native creature of SCP 4000 and treat
these entities with respect and
formality access to SCP 4000 can only be
achieved by performing procedure 4,000
Halloway a ritual requiring a steady
Flame in an indoor fireplace fueled by
only organic kindling Personnel are
required to combine the powdered bones
of one male lion one male red fox and a
Bine whale and cast these into the fire
with a personal possession holding
strong sentimental value to the staff
member performing 4,000 hallway next
Personnel are to add three feathers of a
bird such as a raven or Crow and must
respond with the correct counter phrases
once the fire begins to emit a voice if
these conditions are met and the correct
response is given Foundation Personnel
will gain access to the entry point of
SCP 4000 if any error is made during the
course of Performing procedure 4000
hallway then under no circumstances
should this ritual be repeated staff are
urged to apologize for any incorrect
actions then refrain from engaging this
procedure in the future should procedure
4,000 Hall be completed successfully
Foundation Personnel will find
themselves arriving in the access point
to SCP 4000 emerging from the mouth of
an old well in the center of the forest
exploration teams sent into SCP 4000 are
advised that this dimension does not
adhere to the laws of physical space
that Personnel will be accustomed to
there is a single confirmed safe route
that must be used when traversing The
Forest of SCP 4000 a dirt path leading
in a circuit both beginning and
terminating at the entry point previous
attempts to map the landscape of SCP
4000 all confirm that the only way to
safely exit this Dimension is to follow
the entire length of the path in One
Direction until eventually returning to
the well you have been warned any
attempt to travel back to the direction
you came in will result in a loss of
contact with the rest of the Expedition
team as mentioned SCP 4000 is home to a
number of entities often noted to be
undergoing continuous and dramatic
changes in form these physiological
mutations appear to occur whenever these
creatures are unobserved making
distinguishing between them difficult
when questioned about the exact nature
of these changes the inhabitants of SCP
4000 claimed to have no control over
them and express distress and
dissatisfaction when said changes occur
guidelines have been put in place by the
foundation regarding the interactions
between personnel and creatures found in
the forest and adhering to the rules
regarding the use of consistent names
and titles remains vitally important the
native creatures appear semi-humanoid
and are reported to be highly
temperamental should any staff member
happen to offend one of these natives
they may be subjected to anything from
verbal assault to acts of extreme
physical violence from the SCP 4000
resident if any foundation Personnel
further question why there are so many
rules when visiting SCP 4000 then they
need to look no further than the
discovery and fate of Dr Eugene japers
who during his initial expedition to SCP
4000 in 2005 encountered a humanoid
native entity whose head resembled a
rabbits as the pair shared a polite
conversation the rabbit-like creature
made an inquiry regarding Dr jaber's
name asking how was your name keeping to
the rules Dr japers did not divulge any
name or other form of title to the
creature at this time however japers
remained courteous and polite during the
interaction the rabbit responded with
the following are you simple I'm merely
asking how your name is my name has
smelted of raspberries lately I think or
snapdragons perhaps it's so hard to tell
these days but one makes an effort in
his reply Dr japers made a reference to
his own name as having tasted rather
tart as of late before concluding the
conversation with the rabbit entity Upon
returning to the SCP 44s 3 years later
Dr japers was met with the same creature
and once again engaged in conversation
with it after briefly discussing their
previous encounter Dr Javers was able to
turn their exchange towards something
the rabbit had mentioned before about
finding it difficult to describe his own
name when asked to clarify this point
the rabbit replied I can only assume
it's because of how long we've been aart
my name and I that is it's a good name a
proud name I'm fairly sure by this point
though it's probably decayed from its
former Grandeur if it even still exists
after this mention of its relationship
with its own name it should be noted
that the rabbit referred to Dr japers by
the title fellow scholar the third and
final encounter between Dr japers and
this entity came in 2013 after the
doctor was sent into SCP 4000 with
instructions to conduct a more thorough
interview with the subject it was during
their third conversation that the rabbit
man revealed details of a long forgotten
war between human beings and the
residents of SCP 4000 apparently these
creatures the Fay do not originate from
the forest in which they now reside and
according to the rabbit man's claims
were born in our world much as it
Grieves me to say we were betrayed the
rabbit explained we had fought side by
side you know in the war against that
factory we had done nothing but help
them and what did they do they destroyed
us they took so many of our lives and
all of our names some of us fled here
when the war was just beginning but not
many not many still though I don't hate
them it has been assumed by some that
the foundation was directly involved in
whatever may have wiped out the Fay
causing them to either Retreat or be
banished to the forest of SCP 4000 an
additional assumption has been made that
whatever weapons were used on these
creatures is directly responsible for
their constantly shifting State
rendering them without their own names
or identities whatever the case may it
was during their conversation that Dr
japers in reference to their second
encounter referred to himself as a
fellow scholar to the rabbit in order to
coax information from him however in
doing so the doctor had unwittingly
accepted the title that the native
entity had given him by mistakenly
responding to the name fellow scholar
the doctor had broken the rules of
interacting with the creatures of SCP
4000 an easy mistake but a costly one
the doctor would later leave SCP 4000
traversing the safe path back to the
well and Dr japers vanished shortly
after his exit from SC CP 4000 his
whereabouts are currently unknown the
foundation has made several attempts to
investigate his untimely disappearance
but to this day he remains missing and
the fur left on the inside of his
expedition gear displayed no strange
properties the single goal it would seem
of the creatures residing in SCP 4000 is
the theft of names however this
naturally extends far beyond the
dimensions definition of identity theft
though an unfortunate blunder Dr japers
allowed the friendly nature and demeanor
of the rabbit entity to trick him into
accepting the name fellow scholar by
giving Dr japers a name the rabbit was
free to steal not only his name but his
very identity while it is unclear how
this transference is achieved by the
creatures it is due to the risk of this
that the foundation employs such strict
rules for any research team tasked with
traveling to the forest of SCP 4000 make
no mistake names have more power than we
realize and this is evident in few
places more so than SCP 4000 a pocket
Dimension where everchanging survivors
of a forgotten Massacre exist as
identities alone remember a name is a
powerful thing whichever side of the
well you find yourself on your name
binds you to who you are but if your
name becomes someone else's then one
else of yours becomes theirs too now go
check out SCP 106 The Old Man and SCP
049 the plague doctor escapes for more
of the foundation's journeys into the
strange and unknown